All right, welcome back for day two of this board meeting and seeing that the board members
are present.
Brooks, will you please call the roll to establish the quorum?
Good morning.
Member Benocca?
Here.
Member Burr?
President Darlene Hammond?
Here.
Member Escobedo?
Member Glover Woods?
Here.
Member McQuillan?
Member Petillo-Brownson?
Here.
Member Rodriguez?
Member Rucker?
Here.
Vice President Strauss?
Member Son?
Here.
Everyone's present.
We have a quorum.
All right, we'll start by just announcing that in closed session, the board discussed
or took action on the following legal matters, E.E. et al. Disability Rights Education and
Defense Fund versus State and related U.S. Department of Justice Complaint and Office
of Administrative Affairs.
We will now begin the quorum.
Thank you.
All right, we'll start by just announcing that in closed session, the board discussed
and related U.S. Department of Justice Complaint and Office of Administrative Hearings Complaints
and Californians for Equal Rights Foundation et al. versus State.
As we get ready for the work of the day, I want to remind the members of the public who
are wishing to dial in for public comment that they should view the live stream of the
meeting to know at what time we'll ask for public comment on each item on the agenda.
Public comment may be provided by dialing the phone number and participant access code
and then following each of the operator's prompts.
Upon dialing in, callers will be added to a caller queue.
The operator will notify callers when it's their turn to provide public comment and will
also ask the public calling in for public comment to please turn down the speaker volume
of their computers if you're following the live feed to avoid an echoing effect.
The public comment is limited to one minute per speaker per item.
And board members, please mute your microphones when not speaking.
Keep your cameras on as much as possible to ensure that we maintain a quorum throughout
today's virtual meeting.
For each item on the agenda, there will be an opportunity for you to raise your hand
using the Zoom participant window if you would like to ask a question or make a comment.
And we're going to start the day with item 17, which is the California Community Schools
Partnership Program proposed application process and administration plan.
And the CDE recommends that the California State Board approve the partnership program
proposed application process and administration plan.
Before I turn it over to my department colleagues, I'd just like to express my excitement about
this item.
We've begun to see already that community schools can truly be a reconception of how
we see and partner with and serve students and their families.
They can embody the whole child approach to education as they require collaborative partnerships
between education, health and social services, community-based partners to provide integrated
health and mental health and social services alongside high quality supportive education.
The size of this year's budget, close to 3 billion, can mean transformative change
to the way we serve our highest needs schools, particularly those serving 80% or more of
our highest needs students.
And I just want to be sure that as we work on this agenda together that as every school
is on its way to becoming a community school, our goal here is to meet schools where they're
at and provide support over the full seven years of this program to help students, families
and educators recover from the impact of the pandemic, to address long standings, inequalities
and also to transform schools so that every aspect of the school is supportive to students
in the classroom, in the hallways, in all of the parts of the school as well as in the
services that may wrap around students.
Because we have a lot of other programs coming down the pike, mental health funding, funding
for before and after school, funding for TK.
One of the things we want to help schools do is integrate those services in a productive
way to get the maximum benefit of this support for their students and families.
So the item will be presented by Lisa Borrego, Pete Callis, Steve Zimmer, Indiana Niebuhr
of the CDE, Dr. Daniel Lee will be available for questions and we're going to start with
an introduction from our state superintendent.
Tony, take it away.
Thank you, Dr. Darling-Hammond and good morning to you, President Darling-Hammond and to Vice
President Strauss and to the members of the board.
Thank you for giving me the opportunity to add just a few framing remarks about the California
Schools Partnership Program.
I can tell you that there is incredible interest all across the state in this community schools
grant and I want to thank the board liaisons who have participated in robust and spirited
conversation about how to create this wonderful opportunity and to implement it.
Thank you, Dr. Darling-Hammond and thank you, Dr. Escobedo and your roles as board liaisons.
I wanted to, as Dr. Darling-Hammond said, this is about just under three billion dollars
of what many call wraparound supports, health, mental health, social services to recognize
that students, you know, dealing in the pandemic, that there is trauma that needs to be addressed,
but also recognizing that even before the pandemic we use community schools to assist
students. When a student is hungry, they're experiencing toothache, they have a counseling
need, they can still learn, but these things become barriers to their learning.
Community schools provides a way to help address the wraparound support needs that will ultimately,
once they are addressed, support student learning, but community schools are more than
just wraparound supports. As Dr. Darling-Hammond noted, they provide transformative solutions
for addressing systemic racism, for addressing the impacts of poverty, for helping to create
a culture and a climate at schools that moves away from the school to prison pipeline, that moves
away from criminalizing children, and when you link this strategy with things like universal meals,
universal tk, you know, the kinds of professional development and recruitment that we have for
teachers and diversifying our teacher force and our staff at schools, we are facing a wonderful
moment of creating transformation for California schools, for addressing the needs for mental
health and social-emotional learning, for addressing needs to close learning gaps, and for, again,
creating transformative communities. I want to share with you that today I'm coming to you from
Betty Reed Soskin Middle School. Betty Reed Soskin is America's oldest park ranger. She is 100 years
old. She lives and works in the city of Richmond. We had the opportunity to do a ribbon cutting and
renaming ceremony for her that she attended this year, and she is an incredible role model
for our students about the importance of education. She's been someone that we've been able to name
as a spokesperson for California schools and California education. This school also has a
wonderful community schools program led by the incredible community schools coordinator,
Ms. Mitchell or Ms. Kenitra, as the students call her, and the principal, Guthrie Fleischman,
under the leadership of the superintendent of West Contra Costa Unified School District, Dr. Hurst,
a fabulous district with a fabulous board, and to share, it's the place where I first learned the
words community schools many, many years ago, and I had the honor as a former school board member in
this district to be able to help to pass a resolution that said we'd have community schools,
we'd become a full service community schools district. Dr. Darling-Hammond will remember
that lots of times districts would say those words, but they didn't always have the resources
to really become a full service community school district, and now we do. Item 17 will do that,
and our staff will talk about the kinds of investments that will come for our students,
and I have to say that while the state is currently implementing its first round of
community schools grants, it was schools like Betty Reed Soskin and schools in San Francisco
Unified School District where we got help to design what we're implementing now, and we will
continue to do that. In short order, I'll be naming a kind of steering committee or advisory council
that will inform the entire process about community schools. This council won't make decisions
about who gets a grant, but it will help us to think through all kinds of things like when we
say community schools, what do we really mean? How do we create a framework that is broad for what
schools can think about when they think about a community school and what a community school
will do? Today you will hear the elements of the grant program and how we intend to implement it
and the timeline that will come with that. That will include many key components such as technical
assistance to schools that would like to have a community schools program and technical assistance
to those that already do have a community schools program. And so we invite you to share your thoughts
about how we can improve and enhance the plan. We look forward to whatever direction and guidance
that you provide. You will hear from excellent staff who are versed, deeply versed in the community
schools movement. Like Lisa Borrego who you know as our director of family engagement at the
Department of Education who's worked on community schools and similar programs in her time
working directly in school districts. You'll hear from Dr. Daniel Lee who oversees the entire
effort. You'll hear from Pete Callis from our college and career transitions division who
will talk to you about some of the nuts and bolts of this grant rollout. He'll also talk to you
about some highlights from the current grant. He can talk to you about the evaluation that is to take
place of the current initiative. He can answer any questions that you have. And then there's some
folks I want to reintroduce you to who you've probably met or heard about who've joined us
through the CDE Foundation. And I want to thank folks like Aaron Hiron and Susan Harvey who were
previously with the Bechtel Foundation who've really given us resources to bring on some
additional staff partners to help in coordination of this strategy. You'll hear from Steve Zimmer
who's joined us in a role as Deputy Superintendent who himself has worked on community schools
during his time serving as a former school board member for Los Angeles Unified School District
and as a former teacher and counselor. You'll hear from Diana Nieper, someone who's considered an
expert on community schools who's worked on community schools for many many years and we're
honored that she is now part of our team to work on this. I also just want to say a word of thanks
to the entire Department of Education team and the entire State Board of Education team
who have literally been meeting weekly, sometimes daily, to synchronize, to think through, to dream
and plan. And it is at collaboration that has helped to create the materials that are before
you today for the California Community Schools Partnership Program. So without further ado,
I'm going to turn it over to our community schools team to take you through the elements
of this proposal. Thank you. Well, good morning State Board President Darling Hammon,
Vice President Strauss, State Board members, Superintendent Thurman, and Chief Deputy Nicely.
Again, my name is Lisa Borrego and I am the Director of Family Engagement for the California
Department of Education. I stand before you as a practitioner who was recently in the field less
than a year ago and as I reviewed the community school board item that is being presented to you
today, I was excited about what this opportunity means for students, schools, families, and
communities all throughout California. I am particularly excited to see family and community
engagement as a cornerstone of this work because what we've learned through the pandemic and have
always known is partnership matters. Engaging with and learning from one another is an important part
of community schools. I imagine a rural school district seeing this opportunity and thinking
they can begin the planning process to bring their community together, talk about what they need,
and build a plan to transform their school. I visualize school districts who already have
community schools thinking about how this investment can help them continue the work,
building bridges and strengthening partnerships between schools, programs, and organizations to
provide what students, families, and communities need. It is their voices that breathe life into
the hopes and dreams of an educational system that transforms a child's experience one community at
a time. This is what community schools has an opportunity to do for our California's children.
Today, our presentation is going to cover the application process,
specifically the application process and administration plan, the community engagement
plan, as well as the ongoing communication that will take place with the board.
And with that, I would like to introduce Pete Callis.
Thank you, Lisa. Good morning, President Darlene Hammond, State Board members,
Superintendent Thurman, and Chief Deputy Nicely. I'm Pete Callis, Division Director over the Career
and College Transition Division. I'm here to present the California Community Schools Partnership
Program Application and Administration Plan. CDE recommends approval of the California Community
Schools Partnership Program proposed application and process and application process and administration
plan. The California Community Schools Initiative was kicked off in 2020 when CDE received 45 million
dollars in federal funding to administer the California Community Schools Partnership Program
for existing California community schools. Then the expansion of the California Community
Schools Program continued when CDE received over 2.8 billion dollars in the 2021-22 state budget
to expand on the California Community Schools Partnership Program for new and existing community
schools. There is an additional 165 million dollars in state funding allocated for Community
Schools Initiative. CDE is awaiting direction on the spending authority of these funds right now.
The 2020 California Community Schools Partnership Program, RFA, was published in October of 2020.
CDE received 102 applications. 20 LEAs were funded to support over 150 California community schools.
CDE also contracted with WestEd to provide technical assistance
and to develop a legislative report that is due in 2025.
The 2021 California Community Schools Partnership Program funding will have multiple rounds of
requests for applications for the three different types of grants and one round for regional
technical assistance centers contracts. The overarching goal of the planning and implementation
grants is to create the sustainability of the community school program after these grant funds
have been exhausted. The RFA will be for planning grants up to $200,000 each of one-time funds.
Implementation grants are up to $500,000 and based on conversations with legislative staff
and the Department of Finance, there is a common understanding that this level of funding was
intended to establish an annual maximum per school site when calculating implementation grants for
the LEAs. Coordination grants of up to $100,000 annually are to coordinate sustainability of
community school programs. And finally, regional technical assistance center contracts, RFAs,
we will have a minimum of five awarded across the state.
The application process and administration plan. Community input, visioning, and feedback processes
beginning in the fall of 2021, which will inform the California Community Schools framework.
CDE will host outreach and information sessions such as webinars for potential applicants beginning
in late fall of 2021. There will be four separate RFAs, one for each of the four different types of
funding opportunities. The California Community Schools Partnership Program Application Administration
Plan schedule is as follows. Fall of 2021 through winter 2021-22, community forums and community
input and feedback sessions will take place. RFAs will be published for winter 2021-22 for
regional technical assistance centers. Their contracts will be processed in the fall of 2022.
The first round of planning grant RFAs will be out in early spring of 2022 and they will be funded
late spring of 2022. Implementation grant first round RFAs will be out in early spring and will
also be funded in late spring of 2022. Funding for planning and implementation grants will be
awarded in time for LEAs to incorporate into their 2022-23 budgets. Coordination grants will
come later in the administration plan with round one being in 2024-25.
As described previously, planning grants will be funded
on a competitive basis at the LEA level to qualifying entities for up to two years.
The implementation grants will be funded over multiple rounds. Per statute, CDE must set aside
funds for planning grantees to receive a subsequent implementation grant for at least a five-year
period. And finally, coordination grants are meant to help grantees step down from the support of
the grant funds. They are scheduled to be released later in the seven-year program period.
Now to eligibility, grant eligibility. The eligibility requirements are the same for all
three grant opportunities. The detailed grant eligibility requirements are on page 11 of board
item 17. The main eligibility requirement threshold is that at least 50% of enrolled pupils
are unduplicated at the LEA level.
While LEAs will be the ultimate recipients, other eligible applicants include a consortium of schools.
A single school that satisfies the minimum thresholds for LEAs can make an LEA eligible,
along with county and governmental agencies that will operate the community schools program
in partnership with at least one LEA that is a qualifying entity.
The competitive priorities for the grant opportunities include, there are multiple
competitive priorities that are the same for all three of the grant opportunities. The competitive
priorities details can be found on pages 12 and 13 of board item 17. One of the main competitive
priorities is that at least 80% of the student population at schools in an LEA are eligible for
free and reduced priced meals. Accountability measures for the community schools program include
student level measures, including student and family engagement levels. There are also program
level measures, which is establishment and the expansion of their community partnerships.
Per statute, all grant recipients must commit to providing data as specified by CDE and
participate in the overall program evaluation, which will support CDE reporting in 2025 and 2027.
There are more details on the accountability measures on page 13 of board item number 17.
For the technical, regional technical assistance centers, CDE must fund a minimum
of five of the, as we call them, our tax center contracts. The awardees will be funded on a
competitive basis. Regional technical assistance centers will be contracted for seven years
and required to be renewed annually. Regional technical assistance centers will assist
successfully funded planning grantees and implementation grantees with all of their
community school activities, including but not limited to conducting a comprehensive needs and
asset assessment, creating their community partnerships, creating funding sources for
sustainability of their community school programs, which will include
braided funding opportunities that are at LEAs currently.
The eligibility requirements for the regional technical assistance centers include they must
have an existing community schools department or office, the capacity to provide technical
assistance to the planning grantees and implementation grantees, the ability to provide
curriculum and professional development, and the capacity to monitor community school grantees,
including collecting data and creating the required reports to CDE.
For the R tax, the expected outcomes are similar to their competitive requirements in their RFA.
CDE will provide guidance to the R tax to meet the required outcomes, comprehensive needs and
assets assessment, creating community partnerships, and creating funding sources for the sustainability
of the programs after grant funds have been exhausted.
Including in board item 17 is an attachment that provides a visual of the seven-year breakdown of
the California Community Schools Partnership Program Administration Plan.
So this is an overview of the entire plan that will guide our work in getting the funding out
and selecting the grantees for all of the three grant opportunities along with the contracts for
the regional technical assistance centers. I would now like to pass the presentation
on to my esteemed colleague, Deputy Superintendent Steve Zimmer,
to provide information on community engagement for the California Community Schools Partnership
Program. Thank you. Thank you, Pete, and good morning to everyone. I appreciate and honored
to have the chance to speak with you about our community engagement process.
Our goal as the CDE team is to provide a process and to implement an engagement process
that meets and honors really the depth of what the potential transformation could be
with this community schools investment. So our purpose in this engagement process is to create
a shared framework which supports our aspirations in California for school transformation
and really elevates a California model for community schools. We also through the engagement
process want to build a full understanding of the type of TA that will be needed to really build
a technical assistance infrastructure that will assist both districts and schools on the ground
for implementation. And finally, we want to make sure that we are creating an application process
that is accessible and realistic for small districts and small and rural LEAs,
but also throughout the state recognizing and considering what our schools have been through
during the pandemic, the pressures that are on LEAs, and making sure that we're creating a process
that really is aligned with the community schools vision. Next slide, please.
There are five elements to this community engagement process, and within these elements,
we're going to use multiple strategies to gather input, feedback, ideas, and aspirations from a
broad set of partners. We're going to hold regional forums throughout the state to really make sure
we're hearing the voices from across all of the different terrains of public education in the
state of California. We are also going to visit school sites and hold listening sessions from
the initial pilot schools in the 2020 pilot that Pete referenced. We're going to visit the schools,
we're going to hear from students, we're going to hear from families, we're going to hear from
community school coordinators, like the community school coordinator in West Contra Costa that
Superintendent Thurmond referenced, also hear from educators and practitioners. We are also
going to hold listening sessions with the leadership of these LEAs who have experienced
the implementation of these pilot grants. We're going to hold and have already begun to hold
meetings with statewide advocacy groups, groups that represent parents, groups that represent
students, civil rights groups, activists and advocates, community school experts,
but also groups that represent our labor partners and represent the folks on the ground who will be
implementing the plan that we developed. We're also going to make sure that we're meeting with
advocacy groups to be fully inclusive, so groups that include our earliest learners,
our students with special needs, and our multilingual learners. Finally, we know that
our best outreach efforts are not necessarily going to reach everyone, so we're going to create
time, what we're calling office hours, where we can respond to folks who reach out to
CDE through this process, but also have time to set up additional meetings with partners and with
folks on the ground across the state who have strong feelings about how we can make our vision
for community schools a transformational reality on the ground for students in the
state of California. If we could go to the next slide. I just wanted to expand a little bit on
superintendent's introductory comments. The superintendent will be appointing an advisory
council comprised of constituents. I will include, not necessarily be limited to,
advocates, practitioners, educators, students, families, and community members. And superintendent
will also delineate the process for selecting the members, the terms and the scope of the work of
this advisory council, and this will be based in part on our engagement process and what we're
hearing about best practices. And so we will be updating on the board in the spring on both the
engagement process and the establishment of this advisory council. And with that, I'm going to
turn it over to my esteemed colleague, Deanna Nieberg, who will take us through our next steps.
Thank you, Steve. The CDE team values and acknowledges that ongoing communication with
the board will be critical to the successful development and implementation of the California
Community Schools Partnership Program. Specifically, some elements that will be covered in updates and
ongoing communications include the framework, then also the information sharing and outreach
process to encourage grant applications. Considerations here will include outreach that
helps all LEAs get started early in planning to apply and also reaches their community partners,
targeted outreach to small and rural LEAs, as Steve mentioned,
and targeted outreach to potential co-applicants such as early learning programs. Next, the
accessibility of the application process in general and making sure that the application
process is doable for LEAs. Also, grant allocations, including considerations of grant size
based on school and consortium size and stage of development of the initiatives in the applications.
Also, considering the potential adjustments to the overall timeline based on the number of
applicants and grants made in the different rounds. Next, the system for accountability,
including considerations of both near and long-term student and program outcomes,
how accountability measures lend themselves and link to continuous improvement, and what does the
map for the development for developmental progress look like, and then how this link
between outcome measures and continuous improvement is supported through the technical
assistance provided. Finally, the TA system itself, including its content, infrastructure,
and function. Considerations in building the TA content will include linking to the other
major divisions and work in CDE itself and connecting to other major initiatives like
the build out of the school-based mental health systems through the mental health student services
grants. Also, the work to enhance local systems of care for foster youth and others. Finally,
looking to sustainability, improvements, and know-how regarding to the school-based
Medi-Cal funding streams, as well as Medi-Cal funded mental health programs.
This comprehensive TA system will be built out of the broad engagement and input process
and ongoing communication between CDE and the board. With that, I'll pass it back to Pete Keles.
Thank you, Deanna. This brings us back to the recommendation for the California Community
Schools Partnership Program. The California Department of Education recommends approval of
the California Community Schools Partnership Program proposed application process and
administration plan, which includes the grant request for application timeline,
the regional technical assistance center request for application timeline, and contract eligibility
and requirements, along with the broad community engagement and listening process.
I'd now like to pass it back to President Darlene Hammond.
Take myself off of mute. Thank you so much. Lots here for us to think about and discuss. We've got
the phone line open for public comment. I want to note that members of the public wishing to
provide comment may do so by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the
slide that is shown now. And while we're waiting for members of the public to call in, I want to
ask Member Escobedo if he has any initial comments before me. Yes, what an amazing working group we
had. Everyone passionate for this concept of community schools, and definitely we know the
urgency of it, right? I mean, we heard yesterday one of our students, Alicia, reported that over
30% of our students with trauma have come into our school needing assistance. And we wish we
could apply this yesterday, right, in many of our school systems, but we want to get this right,
right? So this plan of creating a group to look at the creative framework to ensure
this is done right. Why? Because we want this to be sustainable over time beyond the eight years,
and we definitely want to maximize the investment we're putting in for the lives of our students,
but that's what we're doing. This has, like you heard before, the potential to transform
the lives of many of our students and have a direct effect on ensuring that we can maximize
the academic potential for every student in California as well. So I look forward to the
discussion, to hear the public comments, to be hopefully part of the listening forum in one venue
or another, because we want to get this right. And I appreciate also that continual improvement
process that we incorporated in this plan, the technical assistance. So again, that integrated
approach is crucial, and I know we're going to have probably a construct, we'll create a construct
that will be, how could I say, what other states will be looking at. It will be a great case study
in the future. Yes, I'll just sort of add on and say the team at the department has been working
intensely on this very complex process, as you can see, has many, many components and moving parts
and a great sense of urgency to get the RFAs out in the early part, early in the calendar year,
so that by the end of the semester, we'll have places of knowing that they have planning grants
to get going. And in the cases of places that are already up and running with community schools
implementation grants to expand the work that they're doing. So it's a tremendous amount. I'm
looking forward to the framework that will come in January at our next meeting. The law is really
clear that this is a very holistic approach, that community schools are not just places that add a
health clinic on the side, but that they have restorative practices, social and emotional
learning and supports that every aspect of the school is supportive to the students in it. And
so we'll need to really work through a lot of technical assistance and supports for schools to,
as Francisco said, to be really in a ongoing continuous improvement framework for transformation
in the lives of the children and the families that they serve. So it's an exciting initiative.
Talent that has been brought into the department and the talent that was already in the department
coming together in a very active, well-integrated team to do this work is inspiring, I think,
and we're grateful to them for all that they've already done and will do. And with that, I think
we want to open the, well, let me see if there are any clarification questions from the board,
just clarification questions, because we'll come back for discussion after public comment.
And let me, I see a hand up from Member Glover Woods and one from Member Burr. Member Glover Woods.
Good morning again. Would you please, for the CDE staff, clarify the timeframe for the selection
of the regional, the technical assistance centers, the regional technical assistance centers,
and the timeframe for the selection of the first round of planning grant recipients?
So our goal is to get the RFAs out in very early spring, late winter, and get through that process
as quickly as we can to get the funding out to the planning grantees prior to their planning
of their 2022-23 budget. The contracts for the regional technical assistance centers are a little
bit different. We can make the selections, but then we have to go through the contracting process
that we have built into the state, so it'll take a little bit more time for that. That's why we said
probably fall of 2022. Okay, so just to clarify, the first round of planning grant recipients would
know their selection prior to the regional technical assistance centers being identified
and established. It might be identified, but maybe not established. Okay, thank you. Thank you.
Thank you. Member Burr.
Member Burr, I believe you're on mute.
So articulate, too. I'm trying to clarify sort of the overall objective. I want to make sure
I'm clear about it over the lifespan of the program. Is it that every school in California
would ultimately become a community school? That's question one, and then the second one
follows the answer to that one.
I think the intent of the funding, we should say, is to support California schools that serve
student populations with the greatest need. So we're looking at sufficient funding to reach
all schools with 80% or greater free and reduced-price meal or unduplicated counts
with grant support. But I think it's important to think of the community school's approach
and the TA that will be provided that we're building the capacity of school districts
to behave in these ways. And so at some point, we should be able to support districts to build
community school initiatives and add schools to their initiatives, not necessarily with grant
support in the future. Okay. And you sort of touched on my second question. I'm just a little
bit confused about the different terms and percentages that are being used. At one point,
it talks about 50% unduplicated. And for purposes of our general public, it would be helpful,
I think, to clarify what unduplicated means. And secondly, then we talked about 80% or greater
high poverty. So how do those two things intersect for purposes of eligibility?
And I think this is partly to go into the question of how the district eligibility
is defined and how school eligibility is defined. Deanna?
Yeah. Well, so on the eligibility of applicants, it's 50% or greater unduplicated counts
for the LEA itself. That's a floor to become eligible to apply. And then the 80% is an
aspirational competitive priority on the school level. So I come in as an LEA to apply and show
the schools that I'm applying for. And that's where the 80% comes in, to give me a competitive
priority. Okay. And again, can you, for purposes of folks who don't know what the term unduplicated
means, clarify that? What are we talking about? That's a term from LCFF?
Yeah. So it's the low-income students, English learners, foster care. And do we have another one?
Homeless is not part of that count. Okay. And it's unduplicated because you don't get counted twice
if you're in one of those three categories. Member McQuillan, you have a clarifying question?
Member McQuillan, you have a clarifying question?
Yes. Thank you. And this is so exciting. I appreciate the presentation and
this opportunity to help our most vulnerable students throughout the state of California.
But my question is, Steve and others have mentioned that rural and remote areas will have
access to the application. But are there any other assurances that our
rural districts will have a fair share of these resources? Thank you.
I think like we stated before, with outreach and also as we create the details of the application
process, we have those rural and small schools in mind. And I think in legislation, it's why you
got that 50% number. The year before, 80% was that goal, was the threshold. And the 50% gets you
a broader applicant pool. So for outreach, but also the application process itself,
we have in mind the small and rural school districts, absolutely.
And probably worth mentioning something about the fact that counties are eligible
entities also. Yeah, and that in the rural situation, it can be the county office of ed
that would be the lead entity that would help with that deep coordination and the administration
of the program and would be a sensible applicant. I don't see any other clarifying questions
being raised at this moment. So we'll go to public comment and then we'll come back for board
discussion. Hello, caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time begins now. I'm not sure if I'm the caller for the public comment. You are the caller.
Good morning. My name is Terry. I'm an enrolled member of the group tribe in Northern California
and executive director of the True North Organizing Network. A member of PICO California's Ed
California Partnership for the Future of Learning. We have worked in a regional community partnership
with Mr. Jim Aquila and the Iraq tribe and 15 other community partners to create a Department
of Education, U.S. Department of Education, Promise Neighborhoods program. We eventually hope to serve
public schools throughout humble Del Norton tribal land. Two comments. One, we are
strongly in support of this historic community schools partnership. It is astounding and that
gets to the second part of our concern and our comment, which is time. We've heard many members
talk about wanting to get this right and we encourage you to not set February as the date
of your framework. I think we got it in. Thank you.
Hello, caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time begins now. Hello. My name is Michael Juba and I am a classroom teacher representing CTA.
CTA recommends that one, the advisory council be convened immediately to support the CDE's
efforts from the start. Two, that the CDE addresses the reality of the support gap
as the program is starting off. Three, the SBE and CDE work with the legislature and the governor's
office to address the limit of $500,000 per qualifying entity. Four, the RFAs provide
preference points for the creation of a district steering committee as well as a dedicated
community schools coordinator. And five, that the CDE focus their TA center, RFA, on the five
technical assistance centers that will partner with LEAs to ensure that there is appropriate
capacity and bandwidth to support the rural areas. Thank you. Thank you, caller.
Hello, caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time begins now. Good morning, State Board of Education members. My name is Lorraine Richards
and I'm a classroom teacher representing California Teachers Association. California
Teachers Association supports this historic investment of nearly $3 billion for community
schools and we believe that this provides a real opportunity to transform public education for
our students and communities. Overall, we believe that CDE's proposed administration plan is sound
and will be vital to the rollout of the California Community Schools Partnership Program. CTA provided
separate letters on this item. The first one contained a number of recommendations on the
administration of the program and the second was a coalition letter that included 39 CTA chapters
and 46 community groups that focused on educator and community engagement to ensure that this
investment promotes a deep, sustainable, and community-based model. As previously stated by
Michael Juba, he was providing public comment on what the focus of the specific recommendations
were. Thank you for your time. Thank you, caller.
Hello, caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time begins now. Hi, Erin Naphty on behalf of Public Advocates of the California Partnership
for the Future of Learning. We support CDE's plan for community engagement to develop a California
community schools framework to guide program implementation. The framework will be foundational
to the community schools program and inform the RFAs, technical assistance, program roles,
and accountability measures, among others. The state needs to model the values and best practices
of strong community schools by ensuring there is adequate time to draft the framework in response
to meaningful input from the people most impacted by this program, students, families, educators,
and community partners working in schools. To authentically reflect input received at the
community forums and listening sessions held this fall and winter, the framework cannot reasonably
be adopted earlier than February. CDE needs time to do engagement in November and December
and synthesize input before drafting. With the year-end holidays, it's unrealistic to expect
a framework draft before January. The public should have opportunities to review January
drafts and provide additional feedback before the framework is finalized. If it will go before the
board, then adoption should happen at the March meeting or special February 1. Brushing framework
adoption without providing substantial opportunity for community input would undermine the credibility
of the planning process and program implementation. Thank you.
Hello, caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time begins now.
My name is Katie Nunez Adler and I'm the statewide coordinator for the California
Partnership for the Future of Learning. As a partnership, we believe that shared
decision-making at the state, district, and school site levels is essential to making the
community schools program successful. We support establishing an advisory council at the statewide
level for the council to be meaningful. Black, indigenous, and other students and families of
color and low-income directly impacted folks need to be represented. Additional stakeholders,
including educators, labor partners, community-based organizations that partner with schools,
advocates and policy groups, and researchers should also be included. We would also like to
see minimum requirements developed for districts to establish multi-stakeholder bodies for shared
government that include independent representation from low-income, BIPOC, and other directly impacted
students and families, along with educators, community partners, and district administrators.
District-level bodies would be responsible for developing, maintaining, and monitoring systems,
infrastructure, and relationships at the district level to support continuous improvement. Thank you.
Hello, caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time begins now.
Hayen Kimner with the California Community Schools Learning Exchange.
The CSLX is a consortium of multi-factor practitioners and advocates working to
strengthen the community schools field. And although CSLX is new, the deep work of
community school partnerships in California is not. Currently, our work seeks to support,
lift up, and learn from those experts that have been implementing community school practices for
years whether or not they have been calling them community schools. We're currently working to
facilitate a consensus process on implementation standards initially developed in 2017 in partnership
with community school practitioners across California specifically and nationally. And
through this transparent and inclusive process, we seek to complement the work of the department
to name culture systems and practices that are foundational to effective implementation
and identifying areas where implementation might differ based on local context. We're thrilled to
be able to advance this work and look forward to working in partnership with you all. Thank you so
much. Thank you, caller.
Hello, caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time begins now.
Hello, caller. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time begins now.
Good morning. Angelica Honko here with Public Advocates and a member of the California
Partnership for the Future of Learning. Most importantly, I'm a public school parent.
To quote Melissa, a leader with our California Partnership and a high school sophomore,
normal wasn't working for a lot of people, especially students of color. We must work
together with decision makers to create a school where we are comfortable and can succeed.
I don't want to go back to a classroom. I want to go back to a community.
Impacted students and families expect a seat at the table at every stage of this community
school's grant process. We appreciate CDE's plan to hold multi-tiered community engagement
in the coming months to solicit input and feedback and develop community buy-in.
For stakeholder engagement to be meaningful and authentic, it must center the most impacted
students, families, and communities. We appreciate the CDE's commitment to community regional forms
as a step in this direction. Feedback gathered from these forms and other input sessions should
be synthesized and made available to the public prior to adopting the California Community
Schools Framework. And community engagement must continue to be part of this. We're so hopeful
about this opportunity. Thank you. This concludes public comment.
Thank you very much. And now we're open for a board discussion. Who would like to kick us off?
Vice President Strauss.
So I want to thank the CDE team for the presentation. I have a couple areas I'd
just like some clarification on. This is a huge project, and I appreciate
Member Escobedo's comment that we got to get this right and to take our time so that we develop it.
So my first question is about the process of the framework development, the guidance. I understand
the framework development will have input, but I'm interested, having been through some framework
developments, what the process is, because this will guide the program as I understand it. So
again, I have two or three questions, but that's my first one. The development process for the
framework that will guide the implementation, and I assume the granting of the special grants.
Yeah, so for the framework development, it's a major piece of the full and broad community
outreach input and feedback that we're doing this fall. And a big highlight of that process
is six regional virtual community forums where we have partners that are building a ground game
so that there will be deep participation from those communities to reflect on the community
school approach and what those communities see as students, families, and school staff,
and community partners, how they see what a transformational approach would be, what their
community schools should look like in California. And then layered on top of that will be
sessions with, we've already started input sessions about visioning around community schools
where some of the advocates have weighed in. And we'll have those folks look at iterations
of that framework as it gets built, including for those community forums for them to see
a version of what the input they gave and get to reflect on that input. And then we'll definitely
have a broad way for folks to submit thoughts in writing. So just a question. So
and maybe President Darling-Hammond or member Escobedo knows, but is this the type of guidance
document that will come before the board for final editing before it goes into practice?
I think the idea is that it would come in in January. And the challenge is that if we want
grants to go out, if it's going to guide grant making and an RFA needs to be let before,
you know, early in the spring or late in the winter for schools to know whether they've
gotten these grants or just to know whether they've gotten these grants in time to do planning
for the following year, January is the optimal time for it to come before the board.
If you wait until March, then the whole cycle will mean that we'll miss the beginning of the
school year. So I understand that. I just think it won't come to the board. This is late fall
right now. I'll just say that. And we know people will be off Thanksgiving week and then
there's a couple of weeks in December. I just think we probably don't have that much time to
do a good draft and to be thoughtful about it. And I mean, some of the other board members may
have some comments, but I agree. We want to get this right. I mean, there are some clear guidance
areas for people who have experience in implementing community schools effectively.
And I know LPI has done some research on that as well, but I just want to be thoughtful. We really
don't have much time to prepare for a January board item. That's my first comment. The second
comment is I believe schools and district staff are stretched at this time. Everyone's really
exhausted, teachers and leaders. And there's also a staffing shortage at a time when we would be
looking to add coordination and leadership to implement community schools, even in the planning
grants. And so I just want to be sensitive to trying to get this right and recognizing
the lack of additional staff and capacity during this year, which turned out to be far more
challenging than people expected. And so I just want to raise that point. My final point
is maybe Steve Zimmer is the one to talk about it, but it's the advisory council. My understanding
is the superintendent wants to add an advisory council to guide this. And I'm interested in that
role versus the role of the state board and how all the pieces kind of guide this huge complex
process. Board President, would it be okay to respond? Yeah, please. Thank you, Vice President
Strauss. And you are raising some of the key balancing issues that we have here with balancing
the priority and the urgency of making sure that we can get started with what you eloquently and
our callers eloquently have outlined and Dr. Escobedo outlined in terms of making sure we get
this right. So a couple of things. One is that says that that ends in January. And it is, and
we envision a dynamic relationship in terms of our engagement with, you know, specifically with
Dr. Darling-Hammond and Dr. Escobedo as we already have in building both today's presentation and our
process moving forward, but also anticipate the feedback from the board as a whole is going to be
critical not just at the beginning, but throughout this process. And so that gets me a little bit to
the question of the advisory council. So the advisory council, as we've had our initial
conversations with the superintendent and some of our interest holders and community partners and
education partners throughout the state, is we envision that this group guiding and advising
through the implementation phase. So as we, you know, as we begin to see the technical assistance
process rollout, as we begin to see the RFA process rollout, we want to get ongoing input
from this advisory council to make sure that we are hearing both from practitioners,
from experts, and as Dr. Escobedo said, getting this right both in the initial construct
and building the foundation, but throughout the implementation process.
Thanks, Steve. Do you want to speak to, just to go back to the second question that Vice President
Strauss raised about the, you know, current context, the thinking about the way in which
will grants will be given for planning grants, for example, where I'll just note most of the
work goes on after you get the planning grant, so you don't have to have a lot of capacity
on the front end. Planning grant allows you to have capacity, but I know you're balancing that
to the question of how to make grants accessible. Yeah, thank you for elevating that, and we are,
we're acutely aware of the stress upon LEAs right now, and want to make sure that we are
very intentional about the equity goals of this legislation, and really that kind of guides the
heart and soul of the community schools movement, and we want to make sure that the students who,
the students, families, the school communities that have faced the most persistent disparities
have access to these grants and this kind of transformational process,
but we also want to be very aware that we don't want to create an additional stressor or burden
right now on districts, on LEAs. We want to make sure that, particularly the planning grant,
but also the parallel process for districts who want to expand, that that is accessible,
that the initial RFAs are not burdensome with unnecessary paperwork, and we don't need,
with all due respect to all the doctors on the board, we don't need doctoral thesis
in terms of these applications. We need to see the intent, the goal, the commitment
to transformation and equity through this process, and so that's what's really
driving our thinking right now. I just want to know that you've talked a lot about how to make the
application process a smooth one. Smooth one and user-friendly. Right. I see
member Sun, member Rucker, and member Glover-Woods. Member Sun? Thank you. So yeah, I'm excited
about the vision of these community schools, that my questions and comments are related to
member Strout as well around the implementation and how this particular initiative fits into our
larger system so that we ensure that while we're adding new initiatives and more money into the
pot, if you will, and targeted to similar schools, we want to target this money to students and to
districts that most need the support. So how does this fit into, let's say, the LCAP process,
the system of support that we're building through the collaborative? We already have technical
assistance centers as part of that system of support, so where does the tech assistance centers
for this fit into that bigger picture? I feel that we kind of recreate the wheel for every one of
these projects that we add and in different pots of funding and accounting for those pots of
funding and writing the plans that are very similar to plans and to feedback that they've
already gotten from educational partners in the LCAP process. So I think somehow in the implementation
of how this, it's got to spread to some of the system that we currently have. And then also
wanted to speak to the point that member Strout brought up around capacity right now in our system
and with the lack of staffing that's happening right now, schools are having a hard time even
just spending the money that they have that are coming in from both the state and the federal level
to implement programs. So how does this, will this fit into it? And then when there is the
reporting of the funds for how these, this initiative through the community schools is
funds that are being spent on the implementation and planning of this, how does that fit with
other funding that the district or schools may be receiving for similar students?
Yes. Okay. So maybe to start, think about the community schools effort as a way, a second chance
or another way to emphasize meeting the goals of LCFF, but then to seriously answer your question
looking to the TA. So as we build out that TA infrastructure, the content would focus on
how to support these kinds of planning processes and do alignment for your multiple planning
processes. Community schools is not meant to be a sidebar or another effort. It should be
the central effort and include LCFF and not be duplicative. And then also around the TA,
we definitely in building that infrastructure have our eye to what looking at those other
systems for providing TA around school improvement and making sure that when we
build this infrastructure, we're learning from those systems, lessons learned, but also have an
eye to ultimately this is community schools should be the way that schools function in California.
So we're thinking about all of those considerations are being made as we build that TA system.
And then I think you also asked about the staffing issues and I just want to reiterate that the CDE
staff is CDE team is very keenly aware of how much assistance school districts need now in juggling
these funding streams, dealing with the staffing issues and all of that. So also thinking about
the TA that can be provided, building on the TA that's already being provided to our first round
of grantees. How can we get some help out ahead of building this formal infrastructure?
Yeah, I had a comment about this question about staffing. You know what, I think a goal that
the department staff has talked a lot about is that a community school approach at the
district level and the school level adds staff whose job it is to coordinate all those other
funds and services. So it's not another program added on like another categorical. It's a way to
manage that complexity that already exists rather than adding yet another kind of
incentive obligation. So anyway, it should be helpful in that goal if it works well and is
in the places where it works well. The question is going to be how to help people learn to do it.
Yeah, and I completely agree that and I see it absolutely in the presentation in some way. We
haven't really said how this particular initiative fits into the larger system. So I think that's
part of the communication of this is how this fits into our ultimate goal as a state and how
we're doing it the California way, which we discussed for the last four years or so. So
that's really more what my point is to how do we frame it into the larger system.
If I could, Chair, Board Member Son, I'd like to pick up where Dr. Darling-Hammond left off.
The community school's coordinator is a central component to how the connection to all these
wonderful services and supports will happen. There's really no way to do this without having
a community school's coordinator and sometimes more, but I appreciate your question. I do think
that we have to be thoughtful about how all these resources get implemented, and they cannot be
viewed as in isolation. And I don't think anyone on this board or this staff of these agencies does,
but it is a tremendous opportunity. If we think about community schools and how it aligns with
universal TK and universal meals and the $4.3 billion for mental health that is in the budget,
we're constantly thinking how do we align all of these efforts and we will make maximum impact
and at the same time figure out how to help our field, which is dealing with, as you said,
massive staffing and capacity challenges. We know that we have to, for example, we have to
work with our field and we've begun these conversations to figure out how to create
more mental health clinicians who can work in many parts of our state, including in our rural
communities. And so these staffing challenges have to be addressed, but we are looking at how
to align all these resources in tandem, not separately, and I think we can create the kind
of impacts that you're alluding to and certainly keep in mind our existing frameworks that we use,
like LCAP and the systems of support. Ultimately, I believe that when we talk about the social
economics that are going to impact many of those who are selected for these grants,
they are the same communities where we're looking at for the wonderful resources provided through
LCFF and places where the systems of support is available to help support achievement. And so we
have to overlay them and align them and we're happy to work with any of the members of the board and
anyone else in how we maximize that alignment and overlay. Thank you very much. I have a lot of
folks eager to get some ideas on the table, so I want to go to member Rucker, then member Glover
Woods, then member Rodriguez, and then member Burr. Member Rucker. Thank you very much. First of all,
I do want to thank the staff for clearly what was a great deal of work in preparing for today's
presentation. This is a large and significant and important investment. This is a large,
significant and important opportunity and the adjective that I kept hearing was excited and
the noun excitement kept coming up in the discussion and great anticipation is what was laid
in front of me in looking forward to this particular item today. But I have to tell you,
as I listened to the presentation, the word that came into my mind was awesome. Now for some people,
awesome has this meaning that's more, you know, okay, you're about to understand why I'm an
English major, so if your eyes roll over, that's okay. But for a lot of people, when you hear that
word awesome, you think about how the adverb really talks about extremely well or extremely,
or excellently that things are going so well. I'm thinking about the adjective and this awesome is
one of those words that carries dual meaning at the same time. It's both impressive but daunting.
It's both inspiring, great admiration, but at the same time apprehension and fear. And so,
for the community partners and the community of people who need to be involved in implementing
this community schools program, awesome is a very good adjective to use. The department's excitement
and clear, impressive anticipation about the good that this program will do is evident. But what you
heard both from stakeholders and from some of my colleagues on the board is you have another set of
community partners who have a different set of concerns at this moment. They may be excited,
but they're also overwhelmed. They're also having some apprehension about what this work would be.
One of the things I was hoping to hear, while it's very evident that you have done a lot of planning
and it's very clear that you have the ability to do some multitasking, your charge today was to do
some table setting to help everyone understand what it means to come to this process and what
they can bring to the table, but also the differences between the planning phase and the
full implementation phase. As our board president made clear, applying for the planning grant
actually gives you the opportunity to create the capacities that we are all afraid right now don't
exist in the schools that this program is intended to be for. And so, I think as part of the table
setting as we move forward from this conversation we have today to the conversations that have to
continue at the LEA and the county level is there needs to be more attention paid in that presentation
to the table setting, what it means to begin. Putting an emphasis on existing structures,
putting an emphasis and giving a clear explanation in the guidance that's to come on what will be
built up or what will be developed as the process unfolds. And while we can sit here at this level,
we understand that we're at the beginning stages and there's an architecture that has to be built
out and developed and that's the natural outgrowth from creating the guidance and all the things that
are coming down the road. That's not what's really clear or laid out to the LEAs and the leadership
that need to do these applications and do this support. And so, I think that as you do this,
I'd like to think of today's presentation as the rough draft and as you hone out some of the rough
edges from today's presentation, you focus on that to the table setting interest for the groups that
you're charging to do the application and to get into this process and to start a different
relationship with you. I think I disagree with the idea that this is not an additional program or an
add-on because that's the way I heard it today. That's the way it was received. The reason I say
I heard it that way and I received it that way is I wasn't really clear on how the other divisions
in the department are going to be contributing to or even are part of the frame or the architecture
of this program. The example that was given was concerning the LCAP. Since the LCAP and the work
schools do is going to be a central part of the planning and the instructional function of this
community school. I don't see how any of that was considered or brought in. We have technical
assistance centers already in place. And the way this was presented, this was going to be a new
system of support and a new system of technical assistance centers. And I don't believe that that
was the intent of the presentation, but that's the way it was received as if this is going to be a
new and different entity for technical assistance. So I think we have to be more mindful in setting
the table on implementing this very broad, very important program of thinking about what the
relationship is. Is there an umbrella that brings the LCFF and all the other school functions
into the work of what's happening with the community schools? So which is the umbrella?
The community schools or the LCFF for schools that are considered high priority schools and they have
that separate label, is that the umbrella? I think the relationship among all the activities
that are happening with the intent of benefiting high need, high priority schools and the students
they serve, there needs to be some clarification about the architecture of all of this work because
that really wasn't as well laid out as it could be. Because we do this planning and we understand
this planning all the time, we know the difference between the planning phase and what the planning
grant is supposed to do and the full implementation phase, but that wasn't as really well laid out,
I don't think, as it could be. So I'm very pleased that the work that was done, it's evident
that you are the beneficiaries of a lot of planning and a lot of interaction,
but I'm not really sure that the scope and the full force of the department and the roles of the
other divisions in the department are made clear and the functions of the programs that are already
in place at the school site, district and county level are clearly indicated in the architecture
and the full implementation of this. I'm very happy as a thinker and looking at all those broad
avenues, I'm very happy to be a critical friend on looking at those things, but those were just the
pieces that were left out. And then finally, as I said yesterday, we're really good on the planning,
but we have a really hard time talking about accountability. The point was made that the
work we're already doing is raising test scores. So yeah, I will agree a high tide raises all boats,
but there has got to be a clear understanding that the intent is not just to raise or improve
student achievement, but to raise and create avenues for students to catch up and keep up.
And that wasn't as well laid out today for the purpose and the goal for creating these community
schools. That wasn't as well laid out as it could have been either. So planning was great, but again,
the conversation on accountability and monitoring as we go through this wasn't as well explained
as it could have been. So I will leave it there. Thank you. We have a lot of folks who want to get
in, but I do want to see if anyone in the department wants to call up any of the points
that were made in the memo that the board received prior to the meeting, which did deal
with some of the accountability questions and some of the other points. Linda, that's the reason why
I'm making my point. We got the memo and I read that, but there was a difference between what I
read, what I received and was explained to me, and what was made public here. People are going
to remember what was made public here. Right. That's why I'm giving folks a chance to raise
those points so that the public that's trying to listen in, but I do want to also get to our other
board members. But I want to give the department staff, if they want to, that opportunity.
Darling, I want to address, because I do agree with some of the points and concerns that came up from
Vice President Strauss, also from Board Member Sun and Board Member Rucker, but I want to
sort of address them in a couple of different ways. I think one thing that wasn't really sort
of clarified, I think, in the presentation is that this is an iterative process that we're going to
start with some foundational points, and then the goal is particularly through community partnership
engagement, the evolution of the advisory council, and feedback from the field that we're going to
develop. We're not expecting to accomplish everything in year one. We know that in this process,
we have schools who are going to make decisions about what's the best timing for them to join in.
So that's one of the reasons there's multiple rounds for implementation as well as planning
grants. So people can pick and choose when they have the capacity to participate in this initiative.
The other point that I really want to highlight, and I think Board Member Rucker really brought
this up, and also Board Member Sun, was how does all of this sort of center? I think the
conversations that we've been having with sort of community partners is that community schools,
like the framework, the model, everywhere you want to sort of describe it, becomes the point of focus.
So too, Board Member Rucker's point is how are we organizing around that as the intervention?
And then looking at the current resources. So I agree, we are even internally looking at how
we leverage this, not just LCAP. We're looking at the dollars that are connected to our homeless
population, our foster youth, AB 2083 in terms of this. We're looking at how our internal system
of support and improvement can be leveraged, particularly around as we're developing webinars
with Westad around how to use those one-time dollars, and then how to connect that conversation
to community schools. We're looking at how do we not just integrate information from LCFF,
but looking at the titles for sustainability along with Medi-Cal. So we're having those
conversations, and I think the goal that we're looking to do is sort of use community schools
as that opportunity. And I love the point about accountability, because we do have to take some
time, and that's even working with the State Board and community partners, to really outline
what are the accountability measures? Like, what are we going to be looking that defines school
transformation in California? So I think we're at those stages. It might not have been communicated
well, but I want to say that that's the plan, is that we start somewhere, we continue to have
conversations, and that hopefully it'll be a comprehensive conversation and a plan and a
framework that we can agree on. So to Vice President Strauss, I agree, we're not trying
to rush this, but I want everybody to understand that whatever gets developed in January may not
be the final product. It may be where we start, and the goal is through continuous improvement
that we reflect on it, we refine it, and then at the end of this process that we'll have a framework.
Thank you, Dr. Lee. And through the Chair, just quickly, I wanted to just say,
Board Member Rucker and other board members, we receive your feedback. Thank you for giving
critical friend feedback, and that always strengthens every process. And so we will continue
to take the feedback, we will continue to work to articulate how this community school strategy
integrates with some of the existing frameworks that exist for supporting schools. Board Member
Rucker, you referenced it. Board Member Son, you've referenced it. We will continue to articulate
that. Interestingly enough, just to build on Dr. Lee's comments, Dr. Lee is always talking about
how we must create all priorities, must have that deep, deep integration. And many of the programs
that you all reference are in Dr. Lee's branch. And so community schools lives in this equity
branch, as does all the divisions and staff and units that work on LCAP and the systems of support.
And so we hear you, we receive the feedback. And I think that given that they're all in the same
branch, there is this opportunity to create that cross-threading, to create that integration.
Ultimately, that will support the sustainability that I think all of you were talking about. I
heard Board Member Strauss talk about that. And so just know we receive your feedback,
and we will continue to polish up our work here in a way that we can articulate that integration
of all of these efforts, because that's what it's going to take for success. Thank you.
Very helpful. Thank you. I have Member Glover Woods, Member Rodriguez, Member Burr, and
Member Bonanca. So let's go with Member Glover Woods.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. First, I want to just again echo how important and essential
the community schools will be to students who will be able to benefit from this particular model of
educating students. I'm looking forward to updates and information that come forward in
the future regarding the framework that is developed and all of the other updates that
were shared in the presentation. I just wanted to make a couple of points. One, a very strong
request to be sure that during the listening forums, all of the different feedback opportunities for
the framework, as well as the community and educational partners that will be identified
for the advisory council, that there's a very intentional outreach to ensure accurately
representing the demographics of the schools and the students that this model will serve.
I know that it's on the radar of everyone to be sure that we're not only hearing the voices in
the development of this, of those who might be at state agencies, those might be in different
organizations, but I'm really asking the department to do some very intentional outreach down to the
grassroots of the communities to be sure that those who are speaking into the model really are
demographically representative of those who will be impacted by how this is structured.
My second request and or suggestion is as it relates to the development of the framework,
some of my fellow board members have already talked about how this might need to coordinate
and articulate with some of the existing components that we already have in our system. So what I
would strongly encourage is that during the development of the actual framework,
that there is language in the framework that speaks to how the community schools planning
and implementation can integrate with different aspects such as the LCAP that's been brought up.
If there are schools that are eligible for certain levels of technical assistance,
like differentiated assistance, what lens should be used in determining again how all of this
coordinates with goals, actions, services that are determined in those processes, how it braids with
other funding sources. So again, my request is that within the body of the framework
for community schools, this community schools partnership, that there is some language that
speaks to how all of this needs to integrate for the LEAs and the specific schools that
will be recipients of this great program. Thank you so much. Member Rodriguez.
Yes, thank you. I want to say also how excited I am about this. In 2012, I was ready to leave
the teaching profession and education altogether. I ran into a friend of mine who was involved in
California policy, educational policy, and said, hang in there. There's some great things happening
in California. And then a year later, LCFF, which I got very excited about. However, one of the things
that I think the NCLB compliance checklist model is still very much ingrained in a lot of our school
systems, that compartmentalization, which is what was just killing my soul, right? To not be able
to sit down with colleagues and plan, to not be able to sit down with parents. And when they would
say, well, can I come and take English classes here? Well, no, because we can't have adults
during school, right? You know, all of that and all that compartmentalization that as a person of
color, it goes against my makeup. And so seeing this item on the agenda and reading and learning
a lot about community schools, Member Strauss mentioned LPI. And yesterday there was a wonderful
email that I passed on to my school leadership, right? You know, hoping in preparation of this item,
I just want to say how enthusiastic I am. One of the callers mentioned,
and it was also mentioned here about making sure that we have the voices of the community,
Black, Indigenous, people of color. Absolutely. I think that's, you know, it seems to me the intention
and to really take the LCFF and that partnership, educational partnership model. And,
you know, again, to quote Member President Darlene Hammond, that transformation, right? And to make
all of those connections in education that are so essential, not only for the academic and intellectual
building of our students, but just the whole child, the family, the community.
I envision the partnerships with attorneys coming in and civics lessons for parents. There's just so
much potential within the community schools model to really build a community. And one of the things,
you know, to a caveat for me is with the technical assistance centers,
I really hope, and even though, you know, like it's outlined here in the item,
but I really want to see a proactive feedback, the way we give students feedback in our classes
when they're working on projects, how to improve, right? You know, that continuous improvement,
as opposed to coming in and going, oh, check, they have this, they have that, but really engaging
and going from compliance to engagement. Our communities and our students are ready for that.
So I just want to say that I feel that a lot of thought has been put into this. And I also
appreciate the follow-up with the comments that have been made regarding the technical components.
Thank you. Thank you. We have member Burr, member Bonanca, member Patil Bronson,
and then I believe member Sun has re-raised her hand, right? Okay. Member Burr. Thank you,
President Darling-Hammond. I don't want to be redundant, but I will associate my comments with
board member Sun, board member Strauss, board member Rucker around both the sort of overwhelming
nature of this, while there's unbelievable promise and it's super exciting that we have
this opportunity. I think we have to be very humble about the implementation of it.
One thing, and I also want to start out by saying, I think member Rucker mentioned this,
I'm not sure everybody reads our board memos. I don't mean board members, but just generally
people don't. And the board memo on this item is very helpful. It helps fill in a lot of the gaps.
So just for purposes of people who are listening, I point you to that memo and also want to say how
much I appreciate it from the department staff and the board staff to help kind of understand.
I am sort of a practical person here, so I want to get down to some suggestions about the practicality
of moving forward with this and what would be really helpful when we see this in January. Because
we have pretty clearly defined eligibility about this, seeing a list of the schools and districts
who are eligible to apply would both be helpful, I think, to the board, but I would hope it would be
helpful to your outreach process so that you can identify these are the groups of schools and
districts that need the help the most. It might help sort of think about where will those technical
assistance centers be or should they be placed to provide that level of assistance? Because I think
at this point, I'll just say for me, this is so big, I can't get my hands around it to really
understand what the implications are for the actual implementation. And I think more specifically,
it goes directly to some of the comments that board member McClellan made at the beginning,
that we know sort of statistically how many rural schools, how many small schools we have
in this state, especially north of Sacramento, that may need this kind of assistance.
And if we don't see them and plan for them, then I feel like they get left out. In the good old days,
we used to give flat amounts of money to the small, necessary small schools, rural schools,
because this issue about capacity and the ability of those kinds of schools and districts to actually
mount the level of effort that is needed to do a contract, to do a proposal, all of that.
Well, all of the resources that are going to be there, once they get it, are very well deserved
and people will love to have them. It's getting there that is daunting. And in this kind of
environment, I think it's going to be really hard for people to think about that. So just friendly
advice, critical friend advice, as board member Rucker said. The other thing I just want to emphasize
and I think board member Glover Woods brought this up, the importance of those technical
assistance centers. And I think getting those up and going as quickly as you can in parallel
with the planning and the implementation, again, to districts and schools that need it the most.
The one thing, the sort of last two things I want to say is, for purposes of this notion
about integration, and this is me talking as somebody who's the self-appointed historian,
I don't, this comes across, I'll just say this, I don't mean this as kind of a negative comment,
but we have to be clear that this is not a new categorical program, that this is in fact
an opportunity and lots of money to help integrate all of these efforts that we have had underway
for so many years to identify students who have the greatest needs and have been underserved for
years and create structures to make them successful. Because I think otherwise,
again, we're kind of losing the plot here a little bit, or at least I have. So to make sure
about that, the last thing I'll say, and I appreciate the notion of continuous improvement
in the process, is we really need to be humble about the timing. Superintendent Thurmond got
to hear my old shaggy dog story about my experience years ago, working at the state level for another
governor with lots of fantastic initiatives, and then I went, well, I'm going to go to a district
and see how this works, and I went to the district and said, wow, we have all these great ideas,
four big initiatives, we've got to get going, and they looked at me like I had grown two pets.
A, they didn't know what I was talking about, B, they had a lot, they, as all of you who worked
in districts and counties know, lots of things in place and planning that they had forward for a
couple of years, and no way did these new initiatives fit in with that planning. So we
always kind of are out of sync with what we're doing at the state level versus what's happening
at the local level. So just again, friendly advice, be very humble about the timing,
and think about how this all fits in, in the context of a pandemic. Thank you.
Commissioner Burke, thank you for that feedback, and I know that it mirrors the conversation that
we had at the CCE board meeting recently about the importance of field testing, listening to the
constituents, not having the state drive downward, but rather listening to what, at the school site
level, people are saying that they need and then providing that. We will continue with that guiding
principle. Thank you for that and for sharing the shaggy dog story. I will tell you, as I literally
sit at one of the schools that, you know, one of the districts that is deeply interested in community
schools, because we are doing what you said, with field testing, I have to say for a field that is
so plagued by so many things, this may be the one thing that I have heard consistently from school
leaders all across the state, we really, really want it. I think the biggest challenge is going
to be how they apply, and you heard our team talk about how sensitive we are to not making it some
hurdle to have to jump over or through or go around, but people are really feeling like
community schools can make a difference for them, they're invested in it, probably because of the
moment that we are coming out of and being in the pandemic. Everyone wants a community school in an
urban environment, in a rural environment, frontier communities, and so, but we will continue, as you
said, to use as our guiding principle, one of our guiding principles, listening to the needs of the
field, working on timing, and Dr. Darling-Hammond has commented on this, we are juggling some
legislative timelines that have been imposed, that have to be met, with how to also manage the
moment and not rush and make the most of this moment. So again, feedback received, and thank
you for sharing the Shaggy dog story to help. Thank you so much. I think next in the queue is
member Bonanca. Well first, I want to thank the CDE staff for all the great work that has been done
on this item. I truly believe that this investment in community schools is going to completely
transform the future of education in our state, and I'm also really happy to see that community
schools really address a lot of the student proposals that we heard yesterday, like student
wellness and socioeconomic support and the equitable education proposals. I agree with member
Rucker, it's awesome, but while I applaud the efforts to listen to educational partners
in this process, I want to echo the remarks of member Glover Woods in that we truly need to
listen to the people most affected by this investment, and on that same line, I want to
emphasize the importance of listening to students in this process, and I don't just mean one or two
but I think a significant portion of the educational partners that we hear from and consider
should be students, and especially unduplicated students, and the reason why I think it's so
important, especially for this issue, is because community schools, as I said before and has been
repeated by many members, are going to be the future of education in California and are going
to transform the state of education in the state of California, so I think it's truly
essential that we listen to plenty of student voice in this process because it's not just
going to affect the millions of students in our system now, but it's going to affect millions of
students in the future, and I think the way to address this is really making sure that the
outreach is targeted towards students, because we as students get information in very, very different
ways than adults, so making sure that the outreach is very intentionally targeted towards students,
especially unduplicated pupils, I think is something that we should definitely keep in mind
moving forward, but again, I applaud all of the efforts by the CDE on this investment.
Thank you, board member Benocca, and I should have been explicit that we not only listen to
school communities, but yes, to students and to community partners and advocates. We want to be
as broad as we can, so thank you for helping me to clarify my statement. We have recently,
as state agencies, we've had to go beyond the types of places that we use to communicate.
Even my own teenage children have said, Dad, nobody listens to Facebook anymore. CDE and the
state board have to speak through other social mediums, and you're right. We will have to utilize
formal structures and informal structures to make sure that we're lifting up the voices of students
and the students that this is intended to serve. Thank you for that feedback, board member Benocca.
Great, thank you. I want to go to board member Patio Brownson, and then members sign.
So I also want to thank CDE and the superintendent for bringing forward this proposal. It obviously,
I think, has touched off so much excitement, I think, around the state and on this board for the
prospect of a different type of transformation coming through community schools. I would also
just add that similar to LEA leaders, I've just heard an immense amount of community and CBO level
excitement for what it means to make, in some ways, it's almost the opposite of sort of narratives
you hear about hardening schools. It's actually about softening schools and encouraging community
in a different sort of partnership to sort of make it more porous, more inviting to families,
to community-based organizations, to actually partner with schools in a whole different way.
I think the point that board member Benocca just made around different mediums, really,
for how you do the outreach is also true not just for students but also for parents of younger
children. When we've done research around how do you actually connect with both parents of
elementary but also zero to five kids, the parents of zero to five children, oftentimes the social
media that is useful and impactful is not the same as it is for a 50-plus demographic, which
oftentimes I think is imagined to be only the province of students but also I think is true
for young parents. The last thing I wanted to just raise up is this idea of, I agree with the
importance of articulation with existing state accountability formats around LCAP, and I also
think it's an opportunity to be creative about a more expansive set of outcomes to strive for.
There are a finite list of outcomes that are built into our LCAP, and there are slightly more
expansive ones that are envisioned, I think, under the community schools aspirations. So
particularly in the section of the memo addressing what those outcome measures might look like,
I think there's an opportunity to think about not just test sort of achievement and the host of
variables that are listed there currently, but also sort of opportunities for early learning,
for after school learning, for summer learning, to actually be quantified and part of what school
districts can set out for their own ambitions of how they would want to see wraparound services
actually touching the children in their school districts. I would add to this list, not surprisingly,
access to early learning opportunities and also access to P2-3 articulation to ensure that those
early learning foundations are smooth and actually carried from grade to grade to build the strongest
foundation possible. And I think, just lastly, I would say if you're hearing a whole bunch of
excitement but also feedback, it's because it's such a precious opportunity, especially given the
year that we've all had, and it makes it all the more important. Thank you. Appreciate the feedback.
Thank you. And we welcome it. We want the excitement. And in many ways, this is the
beginning of the listening sessions. You all are part of the listening session. You all are giving
us feedback that we can incorporate. And we're jotting down all the questions and comments.
And note that you're absolutely right, that there are, we do have a parent advisory council that we
have been working with that we've launched and established to get more parent voice conversation
into space, and there are other groups across the state. I'd be remiss if we didn't acknowledge that
we've been working closely with the Partnership for the Future, a coalition that includes many
groups. And I have to shout out Mark Philpark from PolicyLink in particular, who has been
crosswalking with Deanna Niebuhr a number of these conversations, who we've invited to be
in many of the conversations in the listening sessions. And so there are many, many people
who are already helping. Your feedback is helping. I think that your point about what we measure,
maybe Dr. Darlene Hammond has thoughts on it too, because Dr. Darlene Hammond has been a part of
community schools for a long time and has been a big advocate and has worked on it at the ground
level, at the community level. I think in many ways, community schools have always been sort of
trying to figure out the best way to show the impact of the programs. We know instinctually
that community schools help students be more successful academically, because when you remove
a physical barrier or a health barrier or a mental health barrier, or even a social justice barrier,
and we completely align with the work to soften what happens on school campuses, to reverse the
hardening of what's going on on school campuses. We completely align with that,
but how do we measure the impact? We'll continue these conversations and look forward to engaging
with you all about the best ways that we can identify to measure those impacts to our schools.
Thank you. I think Member Sun and then Member Rucker has raised her hand again. I do want to
start to bring our conversation to a fine point and a close, because we have yet another agenda
item, and I know that people are listening carefully, so we don't have to repeat what
we've said, but we can add some new ideas. So, Member Sun. Yeah, so that's what I was hoping to
do. I know the staff has heard about the cohesion, coherence, and all that, so I'm hoping that
what we've done in this conversation has kind of shifted thoughts from the staff about the messaging
of this initiative, that from one of this is a great initiative that all we should all strive
towards, to one that might be what Dr. Lee had alluded to is how all these different parts will
fit in to create, and it's a little bit different than how it was presented before. I think that,
you know, being a little bit more humble and how that messaging is that we're honoring work that
has already been done in the field over these past many years, and that the community schools
is the gestalt, if you will, of all these parts, and therefore the technical assistance centers,
all that, is really a means, because we really need a means to bring cohesion into the system
with all these different funding aspects and all that, and so maybe thinking about this as a way
of coordinating these, and that may be very well where the staff has been, but it has not been
articulated necessarily clearly in that way. Member Rucker. And I'm glad to follow Board
Member San on this point, because that was also the suggestion I was going to add. Let me ask you
to also think about, in looking at your planning, to pull back a little bit, and looking at the
architecture of what you've laid out in front of us, where are the inflection points on the
implementation and planning in this activity? And specifically, right now, it is the department
and your leadership councils and your technical advisory committees and centers that are doing
the work of helping districts get started with this, but at some point, the districts and the
school sites where these programs are going to unfold and blossom become the drivers. Where are
those inflection points, and where are you looking for and planning for that transition where the
districts and the local level activities become the leading forces and the leading drivers for the
full implementation of this process? I think that that needs to be considered, and the reason why
I'm asking you to think about that is, at the state level, who your partners are and who your
community or collaborators are look very different than at the local level, when they start looking
at their partners. When districts start looking around the community, they're not going to think
about these statewide groups that the superintendent named that are collaborating with the department,
but they are going to need to look for the businesses and the local community leaders,
the fraternities, the sororities, all of those community groups that have some engagement in
some ways, even the barbershops and beauty shops, all of those people who get involved in the schools
for a lot of different reasons, those are the groups that districts need to know to look for,
because that's where their natural allies are, and I think that those inflection points and those
differences at those inflection points need to be made plain and need to be made given some
appearance and awareness as well. Yeah, and let me just note that that's the kind of thing that's
supposed to come back to us in January. So in an attempt to segue us from here to there, I think
we've heard from all the folks who wanted to add comments from the board. I think there may be a
couple of points that staff want to bring to our attention. I've got to note that maybe Deanna wants
to help us understand something about the flow of the grant process, if that's still the case.
Make a little room for that, and then we'll see if we can get to a motion.
I really appreciate the feedback, because like I told a lot of our community partners in our
conversations, I think we're more closer aligned than what we think, like I think we're conscious
of sort of the process, how we need to be considerate of the system, but I love the point
particularly from Member Glover and Son around the integration, like we have to be intentional
about that and also making sure we can be explicit, and I think that's really our role
in this process. So I want to make sure that when we leave this conversation that that's the plan
and that's what we can produce when we get to sort of the next update. So thank you for the feedback.
All I was going to do is make a point of clarification about the advisory council,
the proposed advisory council, and our relationship with the board and around grant awards.
It's the board that would approve the grant awards, not an advisory council. So just a
point of order. Okay, yeah, that must have been a comment that came by. I think one of the things
that's clear by the representation from the department by Superintendent Thurmond and
Dr. Lee and the set of folks who are all working on this makes clear is how much the department is
taking this as a central activity, which I think bodes well for the coherence and integration
concerns that have been raised, and I think we really appreciate that it really is being
considered a department-wide activity. So we're looking forward to that. I think we heard the
point that there was a lot of good information in the memo that may also be part of the communication
going forward that we want to be sure that that good thinking is also getting communicated to the
field as well as some of the points that have been raised here. We know the department staff is really
busy doing all of this work to get get ready for the, you know, expectation that people have that
there will be some resources that reach the field before next school year. So that is so that,
in fact, that capacity building can begin. So anyway, I want to just thank the department again
for all of the energy to date and all that will follow. We know you're hearing and listening on
a mega scale to both these comments and to others, and I want to see if we are ready for a motion.
Do we want to put the slide back up with the resolution that was proposed?
There we go.
So, oh, member Escobedo, you, I see you have a new hand up.
Yes, I would like to motion to approve the California Department of Education recommendation
of the California Community Schools Partnership Program, proposed application process and
administration plan, namely to grant the RFA timeline, the regional TAC RFA timeline and
basic contract eligibility and requirements and broad community engagement and listening process.
Thank you. Member Rodriguez?
I would like to second the motion.
Thank you. Is there any further discussion?
Member Rucker, is your hand up a new or is it still up from before?
It's still up from before. I apologize.
That's okay. Just checking. Any further discussion? If not, we'll take a vote on the
motion and Brooks, can you please take the roll call vote? Member Bonacca?
Aye. Member Burr?
Aye. President Darling-Hammond?
Aye. Member Escobedo?
Aye. Member Glover-Woods?
Yes. Member McQuillin?
Yes. Member Petillo-Brownson?
Yes. Member Rodriguez?
Yes. Member Rucker?
Yes. Vice President Strauss?
Yes. Member Son?
Aye. The motion passes unanimously.
Thank you. And we're ready for a break. Is there anything else you wanted to say,
Superintendent Thurmond, before we get our cup of coffee?
I won't separate you from the cup of coffee. Thank you, President Darling-Hammond and members
of the board for your action just now. I think that the conversation was welcomed. It reflects
what we hear every time we talk about this with any community partner. There are great hopes and
dreams that everyone has for the community schools initiative. We take your feedback.
We've jotted down lots of notes about the things that you said, and we'll be delving into it
further. So we want to thank you for that. We are thinking about how we do this well,
and we're also thinking about sustainability. This should not be a one and done conversation.
This should not be that when every grant dollar has been used, there are no longer
any Morris community schools. This should be something that becomes part of the fabric of
what happens in our schools. And for that reason, we care about what you all said about creating the
tissue, the connective fiber to many of the existing strategies, and we'll continue to do
that. I also just want to acknowledge that we've had a lot of help from the CDE Foundation to help
us raise dollars to be able to do some of the coordination and to get research to support it.
I want to acknowledge Jessica Howard and her staff and the folks at the CDE Foundation.
There are many foundations that have been interested in this, and we're meeting with many
of them. They're interested in public-private partnerships and the sustainability and the
braiding of funds to make this happen. So thank you for today's push and today's action,
and we'll be ready to report back to you as we go. Thank you, Madam President,
and we'll see you on the next item. Terrific. Thank you so much. Let's take
a 10-minute break, and we'll see you back at 1146. All right. Welcome back. Board members,
we need to re-establish the quorum, so Brooks, can you please call the roll?
Here. Member Rucker.
Here. Vice President Strauss.
Here. Member Son.
Here. Everyone's present. We have a quorum. That's wonderful. We're going to item 18,
which is the new targets for the state performance plan indicators in the annual
performance report for Part B of the Individuals with Disabilities Education Act of 2004,
covering program years 2021 through 2025-26. The CDE recommends that we approve the proposed
new targets covering those years, and this item will be presented by Heather Kalamis
of the department and Mary Sandy of the California Commission on Teacher Production. Take it away.
Great. Thank you so much. A pleasure to be here today. Certainly time flies, and so we return
again to continue the conversation on the proposed state performance plan targets,
along with an update from the CTC. During today's presentation,
you will have a chance to hear about how California has progressed on recommendations made by the
Special Education Task Force from 2015, and an update from our partner, Mary Sandy, at the CTC.
We will then conclude the presentation with a recap of the proposed targets that we discussed
that you saw last time, and discuss a few critical areas to our work of improving outcomes for
students. The themes and recommendations surfaced in the report just six years ago remain as salient
as ever, and so I think it's abundantly clear that the work of the task force report, the state
performance plan proposed targets, and all the investments and workgroups and reports that are
ongoing currently all point and signal to a system, as I stated before, that is in need of
additional changes and shifts in order to improve our outcomes for students with disabilities across
the state. As a reminder, once approved, these targets will be submitted to OSEP in 2022
as part of our state performance plan and annual performance report. In January of 2022, you will
hear how California students are progressing on the indicators, and what we do know is that we
will likely continue to see impacts on our data due to the disruptions of the COVID-19 pandemic,
but more on that in January. In 2013, a statewide task force on special education comprised of 34
representatives from key education partners embarked on a study to document the reason special
education was not as successful and what must be changed in both policy and practice to ensure
and improve services for all children identified under IDEA as having a disability. The result of
this work was a 2015 report entitled One System Reforming Education to Serve All Students, a
report of California's statewide task force on special education. The culminating report published
by the task force in 2015 laid out a myriad of system reforms designed to improve educational
outcomes for students with disabilities. Additional information about the task force
can be found in the March 9, 2015 memo on our website, but the report itself is now finalized
and will be posted on our website soon. Among the task force recommendations was an overarching
conclusion that California's special education system would improve if general education and
special education work seamlessly together as one coherent system designed to address the needs of
all students. The 2015 One System Report also stated that improving how the state educates
students with disabilities enhances education for all students as well. As you can see from the slide,
the report addressed a number of broad topic areas, each one critical and important to the health
of a high functioning special education system. And now I'll take a moment to walk through briefly
each of the seven areas that the report looked at, made recommendations on, and along and recap
some of the milestones that the report had noted in terms of the time frame between 2015 and to date.
In terms of assessment accountability, the task force report called for improvements to how
California school teams set goals and assess the progress of students with disabilities.
The report envisioned an individualized education program process that evolves and adapts to the
changing landscape of education for all students. The report made the following recommendations,
and I won't recap all of them, but just a few. Align IEP goals to the current California state
standards, keep parents informed of the changes in standards, the rationale for those changes,
the implications for IEPs and courses of study, and strategies for supporting
children at home. Ensure teachers and schools are accountable for the progress that students
with the most significant cognitive disabilities make in meeting the standards, and create and
disseminate samples of standard aligned IEPs along with comprehensive training on adapting
those examples or models for use in IEP meetings. And finally, the report made a recommendation of
creating a common data gathering system to record and report on student IEP goals,
monitor progress towards goals, and evaluate implementations of standard-based IEPs.
And as you can see from the milestones before you hear, some of the ones that are captured,
that the report captured in addition is the adoption of the California alternative assessment
designed for our students with the most significant cognitive disabilities.
We have seen the migration of the entire special education data system merge into CALPADS.
There is a, or was, a current IEP template workgroup that just concluded. The report
is now finalized, and so that report does make several recommendations on not only
improving the IEP template in and of itself, but also making recommendations for improving
the IEP process. And additionally, there are, in terms of dashboard and differentiated assistance,
and also the special education governance and accountability study, which is also currently
being finalized as well. In terms of family engagement, the report called for improvements
to family and student engagement activities and opportunities which are critical to the
school and life success of children with disabilities. The report made a few recommendations.
The first one is fully fund family empowerment centers, or FECs, statewide, as already legislated
at SB 511, so that each of the 32 FEC regions has a center. The second was increased funding
to those centers. And one of the third biggest ones was establish a data collection system to
monitor the work done by the centers as well. And as we can see here in terms of the milestones,
timely in the sense of this budget cycle has brought an expansion of funding to the family
empowerment centers of roughly $6.6 million, the establishment of the family engagement
center office at CDE, and also there are new guidance and resources added to the local
control funding formula of priority three, family involvement. And then there's also
$150 million expansion of alternative dispute resolution as well.
In terms of special education financing, the report called for improvements to special
education financing that provides the necessary resources necessary to address the following,
meeting the needs of all students with disabilities, encouraging greater coherence
between general education, special education that is sensitive to changes in enrollment
and investments in the systems and provides incentives for practices that will eventually
lead to greater outcomes for students. The report made the following recommendations,
equalize the state's support for special education across California by overhauling the system of
special education financing to give schools and districts more control over how they spend
their money and to hold them accountable for adequately meeting the needs of students with
disabilities. Ensure the availability of early intervention programs and services for all
eligible students with disabilities and address the disparity of early intervention programs
and services among early childhood care and education entities.
And finally, and again this list is not inclusive, but expand ADR resources,
supports and services throughout the state as well. And just a couple of the milestones
captured here, increasing the base rate for pupil base rate for special education programs.
There is a $656 million allocation for new and ongoing funding for special education.
And again, looking at the alignment of funding and programs for early learning and care.
In terms of early learning, the task force described early learning as essential to providing
the inclusive runway for children with disabilities as they enter the education system.
The report made some of the following recommendations. Increased coordination and
access to high quality early care and preschool for all students, especially for students with
disabilities, children who grow up in poverty and children who are dual language learners
with access not dependent upon geography or service provider. Increased funding to provide
equitable financial support to high quality early care and education and support equity of access
for children with disabilities throughout the state. And again, finally, articulate family
friendly protocols for transitioning between Part C and Part B services. And as you can see here,
the milestones to date that have been captured by the report is the prioritized expansion of
the Supporting Inclusive Practices Program or SIP. As many of you know, that project has been
receiving an additional $15 million of funding over the next five years through this budget cycle.
And then increased focus and efforts on training of the preschool
learning foundations. There is the master plan for early learning and care. And then expanded
support to embedded instruction throughout the Inclusive Early Education Expansion Program.
Evidence based school and classroom practices. The task force report described evidence based
practices as essential to providing the inclusive learning opportunities for students with
disabilities. The report made the following recommendations. Universal Design for Learning
or UDL is implemented and established as critical as a critical area in professional learning for
educator training and has a broad understanding in all schools. That MTSS is developed throughout
the state incorporating robust and aligned systems at all organizational levels that support response
to instruction and intervention approaches and systematic programs of academic behavioral and
social emotional learning. That general education resources are used to intervene as early as
possible with evidence based and multi-tiered social emotional supports
before a referral to special education services among others.
Sorry, in terms of the updates that the report highlighted in terms is noting that there should
be prioritized and enhanced access to the MTSS framework throughout through the scaling up
multi-tiered system of supports or SUMS initiative. That there's currently funding allocated to the
California Teacher Workforce Investment Grant and awarded to the California Coalition for Inclusive
Literacy and that there are statewide coordination efforts throughout the state through the statewide
system of support including the self-improvement and content leads to implement evidence based
practices for students with disabilities. And finally, the last bucket is educator
preparation and professional learning. The report described educator professional educator
preparation and professional learning as a coherent approach to educator preparation and
learning a common foundation for all instruction or a common trunk and multiple pathways for
teachers to earn a credential. California's system of teacher credentialing would ensure
that all teachers both general and special education enter the profession able to effectively
use needs-based interventions and collaborate with other educators in a unified system.
The report made just a few of the following recommendations that general and special education
preparation programs should require all aspiring teachers to master content standards, evidence
based strategies, pedagogy, intervention strategies, and collaboration amongst teachers across
assignments, especially in a common trunk of preparation between general and special educators.
That special education credentials should be designed to prepare teachers and address the
instructional needs of all students and not just specific disability types and at the same time
specific authorizations for educating students with low incidence disabilities, students who
have lost their hearing or vision and for example should remain critically valuable to the component
of special education. And just a few of the updates in terms of the milestones that have
been achieved since then there's significant investment in the Golden State Golden State
teacher grant program for students enrolled in the California teacher credential California
commission on teacher credentialing approved teacher preparation programs who is mouthful.
The development of the 21st century California school leadership academy to provide high quality
professional learning opportunities to LEAs and then professional learning opportunities
for paraprofessionals through the supporting inclusive practices or SIP project.
Last time I discussed the factors or conditions that are at play in our highly complex system
so this slide should be familiar and I want to take a moment to focus on the first factor
or condition that has now reached beyond crisis levels. A highly skilled,
trained and supported teacher workforce is foundational to student success and not only that
we often have seen that a lack of teachers a supply issue often ends up in diminished
outcomes for students with disabilities and students placed in more restrictive settings.
The California teacher the California commission on teacher credentialing or CTC
has been instrumental in bringing about a forward-thinking approach to ensure every
teacher across California has a pathway that we hope will be a fruitful and enriching career.
Joining me today is Mary Sandy who is the executive director of the California
commission on teacher credentialing and Mary will provide an update on the milestones achieved
to date on teacher preparation and discuss the work ahead and Mary I'll turn it over to you.
Thank you so much Heather so are will you remember these lines for me
okay terrific thank you so much. Good morning or good afternoon at this point Madam President,
members of the board, Superintendent Thurmond and colleagues it's really a pleasure to join you
and have this moment to reflect on the extraordinary amount of work that we've done
since the special education task force report was produced. Next slide please I'm really quite proud
of the of the work that we did this was a collaborative effort co-sponsored by the
state board of education the department of education and the commission on teacher credentialing.
It's evidence that when the three agencies come together with a focus there are amazing things
that we can do and the frame that really I think centers this report especially for our work at
the commission can be captured in this quote in a coherent system of education all children are
considered general education students first and all educators regardless of which students they
are assigned to serve have a collective responsibility to see that all children receive
the education and supports they need to maximize their development and potential
so that they can participate meaningfully in the nation's economy and democracy. It's a bit of a
rallying flag for the work that that I know we've been doing here at the commission and I know that
the department has been doing as well. Next slide please and as Heather already kind of gave the
broad scope here this was a bold report and a bold blueprint or plan for how to bring a
coordinated systemic set of changes to bear in special education to improve outcomes for our
students with disabilities. I won't go over these topics again but the scope of this work was
extensive. Next slide and in educator preparation and professional learning as Heather has already
summarized briefly we were really guided by this particular frame that California's system of
teacher credentialing needs to ensure that all teachers both general education and special
education enter the profession able to effectively use needs-based interventions and collaborate
with other educators in a unified system. That seems like it should be patently obvious that
that's what we're doing in schools but it really is patently obvious that we're not doing this
in the schools as well as we need to. Three of the big ideas that came out of this report focused
for credentialing had to do first of all with establishing this common trunk of preparation
that all teachers general education and special education could experience together. Secondly
this concept that special education teachers should be preparing teachers to address the
instructional needs of all students and not focus specifically only on disability types
but to look across the the array and intensity of means and maintain specialized credentials
for low incidence areas where we need them. Finally this notion of what special educators
should be authorized to do the report envisioned special educator teachers being prepared and
authorized to instruct and provide any needed support to general education students as well
as students with disabilities. This really is a kind of platform from MTSS and the kinds of
settings we're putting together where teachers are working together to serve students
in a very comprehensive way. Next slide please. So I want to talk a little bit about the context
in which this report landed and go a little deeper on some of the supply demand and capacity issues
that were present in 2015 when this report came out and really prior to 2015 when class size
reduction was enacted in 1998 there was an immediate shortage of teachers to staff the
classrooms that needed to be needed to be staffed. We hit a high point of 45,000 emergency permit
holders working in our schools before we really caught up with that and there was significant
state investment to grow teacher preparation program capacity and that was a really critical
part of bringing trying to bring the shortages. We almost eradicated them with the state investment
strategy at the time. We moved from 45,000 emergency permit holders to less than 2,000
being issued annually and that was an extraordinary victory in terms of making sure we had fully
prepared teachers working in our classrooms. Also while class size reduction was being enacted the
commission had undergone a revision in its special education credential and one of the things that
happened at that time that may have have contributed to many of the issues we're facing right now
was a separation within the special education credential used to be used to require that a
teacher hold a general education credential first and that they add the special education
credential on top of that and what that led to was a teacher who was fully able prepared
and able to work across all settings in schools. The shortages led to a policy change where the
commission separated these credentials and what emerged from that was more siloed preparation
teachers who were not coming in and drawing from the same core sets of knowledge skills and abilities
to work in the schools and while there may have been some short-term gains in terms of some in some
of the numbers of special educators being credentialed the long-term effect has been
significant and I think corrosive to the work that we need our teachers to be able to do and some of
this is captured of you know following the you know that high point of investment where we almost
eradicated teacher shortages but getting down to facts report documented and that came out in 2018
documented that between 2001 and 2017 overall teacher preparation enrollments in California
for all subjects declined by more than 70 percent 70 percent that's significant.
During the recession 30 special education programs were put on moratorium status
or reduced in size and four programs were eliminated outright two in moderate to severe
disabilities and two in early childhood special education getting down to facts further documented
that between 2015-16 and 2016-17 13.4 percent of teachers teaching in special education schools
left the profession or the state and another 7.3 percent moved between schools within California
combined more than one out of every five teachers teaching in special education schools left their
position which was more than any other subject. Next slide please. So where are we today with
shortages and and and it's still it continues to be significant. We are seeing that we are issuing
as many intern emergency permit and waiver documents allowing teachers to teach as we
are preliminary credentials it's almost 50-50 right now. In 2018-19 we issued 13,340 new teaching
credentials to teachers fully prepared they are in preliminary credentials and moved into the schools
and 13,912 intern credentials emergency permits and waivers.
In special education this is it's the situation is even worse the commission issued 3,300 new
teaching credentials and over 5,000 intern credentials emergency permits and waivers.
We're staffing our classrooms with people who are underprepared for the work and we're staffing
those classrooms and in significant ways that that are impacting opportunities for children.
Two out of every three new special education recruits enter the field without having completed
preparation that's significant this is special education this this work is is not not for the
underprepared all right so since 2015 the commission has approved 10 new education specialist
intern programs sponsored in most for the most part by local education agencies so from the time
of reduction and moratorium we've begun to build back but we are nowhere near the enrollments that
we were in that we had or the capacity and preparation that we had when we almost eradicated
the shortage it's interesting to note that the growth is occurring most rapidly in terms of
numbers of new programs and the development of internship programs there's some very many strong
intern programs that can really assist teachers in training to learn their work and to to to be
effective in the classroom but it's more challenging than a student teaching based program
where you have the opportunity to see expert teachers teach and and have more practice
opportunities than you do when you're the teacher of record. Employers are reporting to us they're
actually reporting to the department of education and we we look at it every year the need to to
hire about 20,000 teachers every every year and that number stayed pretty stable over last several
years of reporting. California institutions are producing less than half that number of fully
prepared teachers so from the get-go where California is not preparing the number of teachers
needed to meet the demand that employers are expressing to us we are currently receiving
about 20 to 25 percent of our new teachers are coming from out of state. Next slide please.
So this graphic simply shows you the comparison between the dark blue column which is new
preliminary or clear credentials and the the furthest to the to the left excuse me yeah the
furthest to the left columns are all teachers special education you can see 3,300 in the dark
blue 5,000 in the light blue column interns permits and waivers and then math and special
and then math and special education. So moving to the next slide please.
What's interesting when we look at we just take the the slice of these data and look at the
intern permit and waiver population of teachers these are teachers who have not been fully prepared
interns are getting are in a program and are getting support and supervision and weekly
engagement with their program and with their employers but these constitute the under prepared
workforce the the largest proportion for each year has been to folks receiving emergency permits
and waivers and not interns so we're sending a lot of people into the schools who are not prepared
to do this work. Moving to the next slide please. So what have we been doing you know at the
commission since the task force report was established the commission has undertaken a
significant overhaul of its teacher preparation standards for general education for special
education and now we are in the process of of updating and overhauling our standards for early
childhood education. In 2016 we adopted new standards for general ed 2018 we restructured
the special ed credential and adopted new standards for it we have built and developed
performance assessments to go with these programs and I'm going to talk a little bit
more about that in the next slide. So a significant driver of change in the general education
standards for teacher preparation has been driving inclusive practices into the center
of preparation of our general education teachers this was a major theme and a major call out by
the task force and the report that inclusion is not a special education issue it's a general
education issue and moving back to the concept and driven ever by the the call that all teachers
are teachers of all students and all students are general education students first and all
students need intervention at different times inclusion was the the primary set of changes
in the gen ed space. We focus in these standards on establishing and maintaining inclusive learning
environments really looking at the environment of universal design for learning is a required
element of teacher preparation and our performance assessments learning about and working within
learning how to work within a multi-tiered system of support the use of technology to enhance
access to instruction including assistive technology for diverse learning learners
providing supportive learning environments for students with disabilities who may also be
english learners monitoring progress on IEPs this is this is all work that gen ed teachers
are now required to to engage in as they as they work toward a credential but I think a primary
theme here is adapting their instructional practice we really have taken that model to heart in the
standards of how we prepare teachers that you will are ever you know what you're doing as a teacher
you you set out with a plan but you must be ready to adapt your practice to incorporate and recognize
the assets that your students bring to the learning moment and to adjust your instructional
practices to meet the needs that these students bring so that's what we've done in general ed
and we have programs that have been up and running for several years now in this way moving to the
next slide in special education the structure of the credential itself was changed we moved
from having seven distinct special education credentials to having five of them the language
and academic development and physical and health impairment credential areas had such we I think
we had one preparation program in each of those areas the low incidence lack of opportunity to
to be prepared in those areas led to a necessary incorporation of that content into the other five
remaining credentials so now we we issue a mild to moderate support needs extensive support needs
deaf and hard of hearing visual impairments and early childhood special education set of credentials
there's a significant transition from the focus on specific disability categories
to the idea that of intensity of support needs from mild to moderate to extensive support needs
where teachers are prepared to work across all disability areas with a with a difference in the
level of intensity and the types of services that students needs in the classroom so there's also an
additional emphasis and focus on language development communication behavior support
and additional knowledge to support students across disability categories so these new
standards were adopted in 2018 they incorporate the general education performance expectations
as the core as the common trunk this is maybe the most significant change we've made in these two
credential areas and that is to establish a set of universal teaching performance expectations
that all teachers are prepared in on their way to getting a credential moving to the next slide
teaching performance assessments have been a tool that we've been working with in California for 20
years initially we were funded with a federal grant to develop a performance assessment
using the national board for professional teaching standards as a as a as a kind of model for the kind
of of reflective work that teachers should be able to do we've built performances assessment
performance assessments and in the last six years we've updated those we had and expanded our
capacity tpas are embedded in coursework and in clinical practice and they have been developed
and updated so that candidates can demonstrate the first their ability to use universal design
for learning to plan instruction where they're focusing both on the assets that students bring
and the needs that they bring to the learning moment in general education the teachers who
take the tpa are required to take a look at the students in their clinical practice
and identify a student who's an english learner a student with disabilities or exceptional needs
and a student with life experiences that might impact their learning and do some analytic work
here what are the assets and needs and how will i use those things as i design a lesson or as a
unit of instruction using udl as the guide for how to do that and then they so they're required
to develop in a planning segment how they're going to attend to those needs they're also
required in this tpa to teach and record their teaching to evaluate and reflect on what happened
in the teaching of the lesson that i designed who got it who didn't get it and to determine what
they're going to do next how are they going to apply what they learned from doing this this is
the plan teach assess reflect apply habit of mind that we're really trying to inculcate in teachers
through teacher preparation through performance assessments so that this becomes the way in which
they approach their instruction the special education form of tpa follows the same dna as
the general education building off of the common trunk of preparation the special education
candidates of course are focused on students with ieps they are asked to demonstrate how
they communicate and collaborate with and co-teach with other educators which is a critical part of
that work and they also are expected to include families guardians in their the educational
process and talk about how they're incorporating that into their work so tpas have been a major
tool for us to organize clinical practice and to really help teachers move from the abstract to
the concrete and demonstrate their skill before they get a potential so moving to the next slide
please so we currently have 141 education specialist programs that are in the process of
redesign to meet our new standards they are being offered by 70 institutions across the state
68 of them are focused on mild to moderate support needs and we'll offer that program
47 of them are focused on the extensive support needs credential 46 of these programs are focusing
specifically on both mild to moderate support needs and extensive support needs we have 18
programs in development for early childhood special education six for deaf of heart deaf and
hard of hearing and two for visual impairments next slide please
back to the concept of dual credential pathways and looking for ways to to get back to some of
the important things that we lost when we separated these credentials we currently have 12 programs
these that are listed on the slide who are these these programs and institutions have been offering
dual credential programs all along and as they're redesigning they are designing that as part of
their their new program as well next slide we did a survey just in the last couple of weeks of the
70 institutions offering these 141 programs that are in redesign just to ask them you know to what
extent are you blending preparation for your general ed and your special ed candidates so
they're taking the same coursework big goal of the task force report big goal of our standards and
teacher ed reform we also asked them how many of them are are pursuing dual credential pathways
41 of those 70 institutions responded and 32 of them said they they either have been or are
designing their programs to enable this general and special education co-experience of common
courses 17 of these 41 programs are designing new programs or continuing their programs that
include the dual credential pathways they've expressed some challenges to us as they're in
the process of of redesign they are of course working within many institutions where these
programs have been siloed and getting the special education and the general education faculty into a
collaborative space to co-design is more challenging in some places than others staffing is an issue
that some of them have also raised while some programs have faculty from general ed and special
education co-teaching common courses others are struggling to figure out how they finance that how
they staff or operationalize this approach they are one year away from having to be offering these
new programs so they're still in the in the final design phases but but getting ready to to be
reviewed and so it's still moving it's not completely settled and stable yet many of our
preliminary preparation programs are offering intern pathways and some of them are expressing
to us concern about how do we go for a dual credential in general education and special
education if our special ed candidate is in a special ed assignment and they're trying to figure
out how at the local level they can get the kinds of cross-pollination and and clinical experience
they need to to add both credentials but they're working on it there's not disinterest there's
interest so moving to the next slide please i wanted to give you a couple of quick examples
Loyola Marymount University has put together a combined coursework sequence that's listed on
this slide they've got they've identified five courses that are common trunk courses teaching
english learners access inclusion and belonging cross-content methods elementary literacy equity
and diversity and then they have five additional courses that are education specialist only they
focus on the practice the the field work component of this digging in around evidence-based assessment
practices to promote student learning and working on effective environments in support of student
learning what's important about the common experience here and the opportunity for all
teachers in preparation to think about teaching english learners together is that they develop
this understanding of each other's practice and the continuum of services and instructional
strategies that are used to to support our our children with disabilities and and this is a
really critical piece that we're driving toward next slide please the California alliance for
inclusive schooling is a group that has come together under the leadership of the CSU chancellor's
office and the thompson policy institute a chapman university that's really focusing in the in the
teacher education community on how to maximize inclusive practices and they received funding
from cedar which is a national technical assistance center funded by the u.s department of education
special education programs they issued us eight mini grants uh two years ago to stimulate uh work
in in either combining your course work or working toward dual credentials
so long beach um used their their mini grant to to develop and work on their urban dual credential
program it's a pathway that's a two-year pathway where candidates earn both a multiple subject
and the education specialist credential it can be completed either as a post-baccalaureate
program or as integrated within a bachelor's degree or alongside a bachelor's degree program
they complete their credential courses at an elementary school site with a cohort beginning
every fall they complete 12 units of student teaching in a high need urban school setting
alongside their mentor teachers in two-year clinical placement model i i went and visited
this particular program and i just have to say that the students and the candidates that i met
in this program inspired me if ever you despair you should go and visit a program like this
uh because the energy and excitement and drive that these young people have for this work
is is profoundly important and i asked them and this is a room full there might have been
40 or 50 candidates in the room and i asked them all right you're going for both credentials
if you're offered a job as a special education teacher or a gen ed teacher which one are you
going to pick the vast majority said they would pick special education it was heartening and
exciting to see and to see their collaboration across across each other moving along to another
example next slide please uc santa barbara also received a mini grant and they've been focusing
on infusing new content into their existing courses and how they're supervising uh candidates
in the field their faculty are working together in teams to develop course materials uh working
on a collaborative supervision model um and a series of co-taught course sessions so they
really have taken this seriously as well and are using the grant to good effect next slide
because i'm running a little bit out of time i think getting close to the end um the university
of laverne is another case where they have have used their mini grant to uh to really deepen their
partnerships with local schools where they use do their clinical practice and co-teaching their
their uh their common trunk forces are taught by ed specialist faculty and general and faculty
together to great effect moving on to the next slide i just want to quickly say that the story
that i drew earlier about shortages is dire and it would be extremely uh dire if we didn't have
the kind of investments that we've had and and that are available right now in the last several
years we we had a 10 million dollar grant fund that to support the development of undergraduate
pathways for stem and special ed we issued 41 grants of 250 thousand dollars each for planning
two institutions that had these programs they developed 90 distinct program pathways 18 of
them in special education we had 400 students enrolled in the 1920 year across all program
types 95 of them in special education 13 degree and credentials issued to date in special education
50 million dollars for local solution grants funding to support the hiring of 3600 teachers
in special education also very successful program and very popular with the local education agencies
where they could use these funds for loan repayment they could offer that to the to their new hires
signing bonuses stipends the extra stipends for special education teachers etc more than
2000 individual candidates have participated or teachers have participated in this program to date
45 million dollars for the classified school employee teacher grant this has been a very
popular grant program we have 44 lea is currently funded to support 2260 classified staff 13 more
than 1300 have been credentialed so far 619 of them in special education this program has
125 million dollars beginning this year for expansion next slide
51 million dollars was made available initially to support teacher residency grant programs
37 grants were issued to date 234 residents were enrolled last year just under half of
them in special education 70 are completing their programs in a year others are in are taking 18
months if they're adding special education 70 of the residents enrolled in this program self
identify as people of color so we're having removing the needle on diversifying the teaching
profession key goal also that's similar statistic available for the classified grant program
um we have 350 million dollars in our budget to give away over the next five years which
will support up to 13 000 residents critical program critical strategy for lea's experiencing
shortages additionally there's the 500 million dollar grant fund for the golden state teacher
grant that'll support up to 25 000 teachers coming in over the over the coming years next next slide
please
so in you know in summary we took the task force report seriously we were faced with conditions
that were dire as we saw the reduction of capacity from the class size reduction high point
to to today those those reductions in capacity have been significant and they're still with us
we believe in the credentialing process we've set the stage to prepare the teachers that we need for
our students in a common uh trunk of preparation with areas of specialization and the ability to
move seamlessly into mtss settings and this is important stage setting and moving on to the final
slide i just want to end with some what are some next steps that that we think are necessary in
order to really um turn the corner first of all the data i shared with you earlier it it
definitely suggests if it doesn't shout that we need to double the number of teachers coming
through teacher preparation programs in california if we're going to address shortages and and uh
keep up with demand uh secondly that and and what's what is going to be required there is to really
build institutional capacity or to rebuild it if you will to prepare special education teachers
multiple subject teachers are another area of shortage and with uh universal transition
kindergarten coming down the pike that situation could get worse if we don't begin to really
make sure our our preparation programs can produce the numbers of teachers that we need
the expansion of mtss is really also quite necessary we need more clinical practices
practice sites and settings in mtss settings if we really want the workforce we're preparing to get
it and be able to work within it finding a way to incentivize the development of dual credential
programs and blended preparation for general and special education teachers is also something
uh that would be extremely useful and finally collectively we have to be thinking about in
problem solving around attrition in the teaching force across the board and particularly in special
education and as has been quoted to me as recently as last night if we can cut our
attrition in half we will address the teacher shortage so thank you so much for giving me
the opportunity to join heather in this presentation and i'll turn it back over to you now
you know
great thank you so much mary um it's it's clear the numbers are um astonishing um that that you
um you know to walk us through the beginning of the beginning of your presentation but you know i
think it's it's extremely encouraging to to to see and hear and know um the uh the ctc is is um sort
of leading the charge and ensuring that um you know our our workforce our workforce um is is poised
to sort of meet the challenges ahead in terms of ensuring that we have a high quality um highly
trained teacher in in every single special education classroom so um and now just it's it's you know i
want to spend some time um sort of shifting our focus back into the proposed um indicators um and
really talk about sort of what's next and sort of what's important for for us to focus on in order
to improve some of those outcomes as mary has indicated um you know teacher workforce is is
critical to that um in terms of the solving the puzzle and so i'm glad that we were able to to
capture that conversation here today and so we believe that a successful school experience is
heavily influenced by an educational setting or least restrictive environment as we term it
students that begin in a highly segregated settings tend to stay in those restrictive
settings over time throughout their educational career and as i stated at the last board meeting
educational setting is often has a correlation or direct correlation to student behavior which
oftentimes can result in removal from educational settings or removal into lesser i'm sorry more
restrictive settings um you know as as we know um and so it's it's the iop team decision of how
supports and services will be provided is such an important conversation as we know um again that
inappropriate settings lead to increased behaviors that can also lead to suspension and expulsion
therefore a lack of access to um curriculum and teaching and learning and again ensuring students
are making progress towards statewide standards is also an indicator of how effective the supports
and services are in providing the tools necessary for students to access the curriculum and as we
head towards graduation ensuring our students are equipped with the skills and tools necessary to
navigate post navigate life post school is a huge monumental task and requires the efforts of many
both at the agency level and the local level to ensure that our students graduate high school
and have a clear pathway ahead in terms of what that means for for their future and able to make
meaningful contributions to the community that they live in
in terms of the targets themselves just want to recap um the uh the targets that we went through
last time i will not walk through every single target but did want to provide just a brief
overview of the trajectory that we have laid out over the next six years in terms of ensuring that
we are one first and foremost creating rigorous targets as that is is obviously key to maintain
a high level of high standards in terms of what we expect um you know in terms of the performance
for for our students and so just again don't want to walk through them all but did want to note
note to you that in indicator three the third line down you see the the word various and various
just denotes that if you remember last time that the that indicator now is split out into three
grade levels four eight and eleven to to greater capture growth or or lack thereof growth and so
that information can be found in page 12 of your of your packet if you want to take a look at those
targets as well um did want to notice uh note as well that um the uh there are compliance targets
that are set uh strictly by ossep and ossep set those targets and the california department of
education um must must meet them and those are uh 4b suspension expulsion by race race and ethnicity
nine which i'll scroll to the next one um disproportionate representation and ten
disproportionate representation by disability categories 11 child find 12 early childhood
transition and then 13 which is post-secondary transition so again those are set by ossep
and the rest of those were set by the the group of educational partners
that was convened by cde over over the previous years as well
um
i would just like to note that at about one o'clock our closed captioning um vendors are slated to
leave so we should try to um move to uh public comment soon all right so uh last slide here in
terms of just the targets um again those are in your packet and we reviewed those last time
so again in terms of how will cde get to improved outcomes for students and really thinking about
lre is the foundation of our theory of action right in terms of you know what what are sort
of critical factors in improving those outcomes one it constitutes the right the right placement
as i mentioned before in that place with the right supports and services and in that placement um
not only are there the right supports and services but those are being delivered in a
in a high quality manner and and in theory obviously a reduction in behavior should be
occurring in classrooms and increased learning through achievement through through multiple
measures is is our goal and obviously graduation and and post-school achievement is is our end
game to ensure again that the outcomes for our students in terms of facing facing life
is is one in which there are choices for a student and there's also a a clear pathway ahead for them
as well in terms of how and again this slide was in in the last presentation monitoring and support
for students with disabilities our approach here again as you see on the triangle an inverted
triangle how many las are in our intensive targeted in universal tiers which we
um uh annually designate lea's each january into into those tiers and then obviously
the related support that they receive either from the cde or from our ta partners out in the field
as well in terms of our focus on least restrictive environment here again lea selected for intensive
monitoring um you know are are ones that are are the in the lowest assail and providing a free
appropriate public educational least restrictive environment we'll be focusing on lre and faith
for all monitoring activities with an emphasis on ensuring the most inclusive placement as possible
and ta will be focused as well turning to early childhood and and also realizing that
inclusive inclusion and inclusive environments in early childhood is critical as we know that a
uh a strong start for our students is key in inclusive settings and so just wanted to highlight
some of the funding the 260 million dollars in early intervention special education funding
designed to support early early intervention services wraparound services and expansion of
inclusive practices the california state preschool program again the budget provided 130 million
dollars for expansion which is again huge for our students especially for our students with
disabilities and then the expansion of universal tk in the sense that the phase end will include
obviously all four-year-old children and including students with disabilities and so
i'm looking forward to to the ramp up and and planning around that as well
in terms of current special education investments mary went over these and so i'm not going to recap
all of them but again wanted to note that there is an additional 450 million dollars in special
education learning recovery so that critical supports and services can be provided additional
critical supports and services can be provided to students especially to address the impacts of
kovat 19 100 million dollars in alternative dispute resolution so that issues regarding
the ip or ip process or supports and services can be addressed in a manner that allows all parties to
come to an agreement at the table and then again the 20 million dollar increase
it should be 15 and in supporting inclusive practices as well
so with that i will conclude and we are requesting that the proposed targets for the
performance indicators for the next six-year cycle of the state performance plan covering years 2021
through 2526 be considered by the sbe for for approval and again we're recommending approval
of those targets as well thank you so much it's really helpful to get such an overview of what we
need to do to get there so that the targets are you know more than numbers on on the page
we want to move to public comment and we have the public comment slide
up and those who wish to provide such comment may do so by calling the telephone number
and using the access code provided on the slide that is shown now and while we're waiting for
members of the public to call in i want to ask vice president strouse if she has any initial comments
and then we'll take any clarifying comments if there are any before we take public comment
thank you president darling ham and i want to thank you heather and mary for presenting
really a good focus on we know this is a federal requirement that we have to complete for every six
years but i i think your highlight in the presentation was it's really a guidance it's
guiding our process to continue to improve support and services for students with disabilities to
for students with disabilities to increase their opportunities for achievement and and i think
i appreciated some highlights and i just want to reinforce that before we hear from our public
comments we've been hearing this at the special ed advisory group but the iep template group that
came out of this process is very exciting to hear about as we improve the process the governance
and accountability study very helpful those of us who've worked with special ed in local school
districts recognize the challenges and i think from the special ed task force that happened
several years ago lots of implications around credentialing funding template will improve the
program overall and for those of us who were trained before the common trunk of training for
teachers with credentials it was a very siloed program and i i really appreciate mary you
highlighting the efforts that ctc has worked on try to give all teachers a common trunk of preparation
because we are moving toward all teachers doing first level intervention in mtss which you
highlighted which is a transition that districts are embracing and i appreciate the focus on
teacher preparation again it's a challenge that districts continue to work on and i think the
teacher preparation program will assist that as well so i appreciate you highlighting that also
the link to the system of support because districts have identified the students with
disabilities as a lower performing subgroup that they want to focus on and a lot of mtss work
is focused on that also the early learning work which we've been talking about at our board
meetings and the work huge investments in our state budget for teacher recruitment and support
and early learning and system of support and educator professional trainings it just is so
exciting to see all this investment and the coordination and i just want to kind of close
my comments by saying that this requirement to complete this process really is guiding our work
toward improvement it is helpful to the process and while it's very comprehensive and i appreciate
the two presentations heather from the last board meeting and this one i think for all of us to
realize what an important effort it is to try to change a system as we're working in it to improve
teacher abilities to deliver support how districts view this and the least restrictive environment
so again i appreciate it i think that we've come a long way we have a lot of work ahead
so we have a lot of funding and programs but we have to continue on the road ahead so i thank
you very much on aisle when we're ready i'll be ready to make a recommendation to support thank
you thank you uh let me ask um i don't see any clarifying questions um to be answered so i want
to see if we have any public commenters we do not have public comment all right terrific um and so i
think we're ready for any board discussion on this item and i will um just start us off on that by
sort of adding on to vice president straw's comments and to note that in that theory of
action which if you would put the theory of action back up i like that little graphic
i'm so glad that we're looking at all of these pieces because to get the right instruction in
the right placement we have to solve the teacher supply and credentialing problems that have
prevent have really led us to this much more siloed approach in the past and i want to ask
just quickly ask both heather and mary as you look at what is being put together where we're heading
what we need to have in place to accomplish the targets because we can set the targets but we
actually want to reach them are there particular things that you want us to be aware of as
um needed uh beyond what's already in motion uh to help us get there
i'll go ahead and go um i you know i think in terms of you know really bringing this this work
to life uh is is you've as you've mentioned requires um you know first and foremost a
recognition that um the the system is operated by individuals um and i think really ensuring that
you know our individuals are not only equipped but also you know we are able to hold and have
deep conversations about students with disabilities hold deep conversations around philosophy
and mindset towards supporting students with disabilities and their families and their
communities and really you know an honest conversation about just looking at our system
as a whole from from essentially start to finish and really carving out time i think to have some
of those deeper conversations i think um you know uh elaine mentioned um the fact that we are
essentially oftentimes doing the work and making making refinements as we go but also i think you
know stepping back um often to to really look at our system and its effectiveness and the in the
in really support and surface issues that are bubbling up um on sort of the human side of the
work um as that is often i think a critical a critical factor in addition to to getting to
to some of these targets in the in the systems that we have before us as well
thank you and this is sort of part of that process that we need to
keep coming around on mary anything to add i just to just to underscore that we we have programs
in place we need to increase the numbers of people coming through them we need to build program
capacity to prepare the workforce that we need and and that you know that is maybe an easier
problem to get our arms around than uh really intervening around attrition um because that's
that is that's very local and um but but i think there's a significant issue that we need to attend
to which is how we retain the the teachers that we do bring into teaching as you know undoubtedly
as we've heard from other presentations workload questions associated with that as well as
training and mentoring questions so absolutely thank you any other board discussion before we
get to a motion uh member rodriguez yes i just want to thank um both uh heather and mary for
that fantastic presentation and for have starting out you know with such the dire and it is a dire
need for our teacher shortage but ending on such a positive note with the students in long beach
and ucsb and um you know it just i i could imagine that room and and i'm excited that there
are incoming teachers who are so excited about working um in special ed and and teachers who
are coming in who have that preparation even though they're generalists so thank you so much
uh seeing no other commentary uh can i get a motion oh i'll move approval of this item
thank you second i will second it thank you very much any further discussion
all right uh bricks will you call the roll call vote member banaka hi member burr
aye president carlin hammond aye member escapado yes member glover woods yes member mcquillin
yes member patillo brownson yes member rodriguez yes member rocker yes vice president strouse
yes member sun
aye passage unanimously thank you uh much appreciated thank you mary thank you heather
thank you all board members we are done with our agenda and i hereby adjourn our november
2021 state board of education meeting at 12 53 p.m see you in january